ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
COMMUNICATIONS CONVEYANCE.
SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS NOTING THAT
THERE IS AN ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
I WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE-
AND A COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS
MR CHANG AND MR BENNETT WILL BE
APPOINTED TO THE COMMITTEE TO
FILL THE VACANCY FOR TODAY'S
HEARING- ONLY. IN THE INTEREST
OF MOVING US FORWARD. LIKE TO
START. WITH THE FIRST BILL AB
NINE EIGHT EIGHT WHERE CAN. I
MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- FIRST I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR FOR HIS
SUPPORT IN ENSURING THAT THIS
TRANSFORMATIONAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ACHIEVES MISTER
CAMP I AM MADE AN ERROR. WE ARE
NOW BECAUSE I HAVE TO DO THE-
SIPO TO ALL IN THE INTEREST OF
MOVING YOU QUICKLY I- FOR WHAT
THE ANNOUNCEMENTS ALL START-
GOOD AFTERNOON AND- TODAY WE'RE
GONNA BE PRACTICING SOCIAL
DISTANCING HIM HEARING ROOMS
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO YOU'LL BE SO WE'LL
ONLY BE ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE- WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON WERE ALSO
REQUIRED TO THE MASS BE WORN A
PHYSICAL THIS IS BE MAINTAINED
BY ALL INDIVIDUALS HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. AND THEN THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM- WE
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR- WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY
PUBLIC TESTIMONY OPTIONS
INCLUDE TESTIFYING- FROM THE
WITNESS ROOM. ARE ON THE PHONE
OR VIA REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
ON THE NORTH SIDE OF THE
CAPITOL AS A REMINDER WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE CHAMBER OR-
REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. FOR
THOSE THE BILL FOR THE PUBLIC
IN- IN THE ROOM. FOR ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TEST THE FINAL BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND. I WILL ASK YOU
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
ASK THE PUBLIC NOT TO TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. FOR THOSE DAHLE AND
WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE USING
MODERATED. A TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH- ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL- THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINETEEN. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWO FOUR. TWO SIX. TWO THREE
SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
COMMUNICATIONS AND CAMPAIGNS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE- PLANTED USE
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL TESTIFYING.
IS BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. HE ALSO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE UNTIL IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. IS ELIMINATE
ALL BLACK BACKGROUND NOISES-
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM I BROADCAST IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE- SOUND
DISTORTION. NOT TO MENTION
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A PAUSE
SO YOU'LL ALWAYS BE OFF- OFF BY
A FEW SECONDS. SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL BE BLENDED IN
THE PHONE LINES JUST KEEP THE
MEETING MOVING A LITTLE BIT
QUICKER. AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU WERE CAPTURED AND BE ABLE
TO TESTIFY. PLEASE BE ADVISED
THAT YOU'LL BE THERE IF YOU ARE
THE MAIN WITNESSES PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL. YOU WILL REMAIN ON THE
LIVE LINE YOU'LL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF. UNTIL YOU ARE BEING
CALLED ON TO SPEAK AGAIN- I
WOULD PAY ATTENTION TO THE
PHONE. RATHER THAN TO THE LIVE
STREAM OR NOISE BECAUSE YOU
WILL ALWAYS BE BEHIND A MINUTE.
IF YOU'RE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH
A MODERATE A PHONE SERVICE. YOU
CAN CALL COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO SIX.
THREE SEVEN I REPEAT THAT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE. TWO
SIX THREE SEVEN. I AND OUR TEAM
WILL BE THERE TO HELP YOU ALSO
ONE OF THE WRECK SEPT IN
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGHPUT.
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE.
TO OUR FINAL POINT. IS SOME IS
EXPERIENCING OF ASSUMPTIONS. I
TO COMMITTEE AND FLOOR
PROCEEDINGS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. CONTACT AT RISK CONTACT
THAT REFER UPS DISTURB OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDE ORDERLY
CONDUCT A MEETING IS PROHIBITED
SUCH CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE I
REMOVED THE MASK AND REFUSING
TO PUT IT BACK ON TALKING OR
MAKING LOUD NOISES DURING THE
AUDIENCE UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING AND ABUSIVE
LANGUAGE AND OTHER DISRUPTIVE
ACTS TO ADDRESS ANY DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT I WILL TAKE THE
FOLLOWING STEPS. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL IS DISRUPTED DURING
HER PROCESS I WILL DIRECT THEM
TO STOP AND WORN AND DOES IT
THAT IF THERE CONTINUE TO
SUBSTANCE THIS MAY RESULT IN
THE MOVE REMOVAL OF THE CAPITOL
BUILDING ALL ALSO DOCUMENT- ON
THE RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED IN NATURE THIS RISK
DESTRUCTIVE ACTION- AND I MAY
TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. IF THIS CONDUCT DOES
NOT STOP ALL REQUEST ASSISTANT
OF THE ART OF THE ERGEANT
RAIMES- IN ESCORTING A
INDIVIDUAL- FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE MISTER KEAN UNIVERSITY
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR-
SO I WANT TO FIRST THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR SPPORT
FOR THIS TRANSFORMATIONAL PIECE
OF LEGISLATION BUT ALSO I THINK
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR DEEP ENGAGEMENT AND
OUR CONVERSATIONS ON. HOW TO
ACHIEVE THE GOAL THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN THIS
LEGISLATION AND I WANT EVERYONE
TO KNOW THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO I'M SURE WE'LL
HEAR FROM TODAY INCLUDING THE
TELECOMMUNICATION
COMMUNICATIONS AND CABLE
INDUSTRIES WHO WE MET WITH THIS
RECENTLY AS YESTERDAY TO
CONTINUE TO REACH COMMON GROUND
WE ALSO CONTINUE OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH S. C.
A. U. N. C. V. H. D. A. TO
ENSURE THAT THE- THAT THIS IS
IN. IN A WAY THAT IS WORK. FOR
A- IN OUR WORKERS. WELL WE
DIDN'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
AMEND THE BILL IN THIS
COMMITTEE I WANT TO STATE ON
THE RECORD AS I'VE SAID TOO
MANY OF YOU THAT I'LL BE
AMENDING THE BILL AT THE NEXT
OPPORTUNITY WHICH MAY BE ON THE
FLOOR DEPENDING WHAT HAPPENS IT
APPROPRIATIONS. TO CAPTAIN NINE
EIGHT EIGHT FEE AT EIGHTY CENTS
PER LINE PER MONTH TO PUT IT IN
PARITY WITH NINE ONE ONE. THE
FEE WILL FUNCTION VERY
SIMILARLY TO NINE ONE ONE FOR
THE NOT THE EIGHTY CENTS WILL
SERVE AS A CAP BUT THE ACTUAL
COST OF THE FEE WILL BE SET.
BY- YES DOING AN ACTUAL COST
ANALYSIS AND THEN BRINGING THAT
NUMBER TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
APPROVAL SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO
APPROVE THE ACTUAL FEET. ONCE
YES HAS THAT COST ESTIMATE BUT
IT WILL NEVER BE ALLOWED TO GO
ABOVE EIGHTY CENTS. THE
NINETEEN EIGHTY SHOULD NOT
BECOME THE BACKSTOP FOR THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM. OF MENTAL HEALTH
CARE. BUT WE SHOULD BE ENSURING
THAT THE SYSTEM TO BE ABLE TO
RUN SMOOTHLY AND THAT PEOPLE
CAN AND DO YOU HAVE ACCESS. TO
THE CARE THEY NEED. LAST YEAR
BOTH CHAMBERS OF CONGRESS
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED. BECAUSE
THERE COULD THAT INCREDIBLE
THINGS. THEY CONGRESS
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED THE
UNDERLYING LEGISLATION. AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE HOTLINE
DESIGNATION ACT. ESTABLISHING
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT AS THE NEW
THREE DIGIT ALTERNATIVE TO NINE
ONE ONE. FOR SUICIDE AND MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS. STATES SUCH AS
WE ARE ARE NOW WORKING TO
IMPLEMENT THE NINETY EIGHT
SYSTEM. AND BY JULY. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO NINE EIGHT EIGHT
WILL GO LIVE. AB NINE EIGHT
EIGHT ALSO KNOWN AS THE MILES
CALL LIFELINE IN SUICIDE
PREVENTION ACT IMPLEMENTED THIS
NEW NINE EIGHT EIGHT SYSTEM
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. TO PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS WITH AROUND THE
CLOCK MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS CARE
INCLUDING. CRISIS COUNSELORS
WHO CAN PROVIDE LIFESAVING CARE
OVER THE PHONE IN 95% OF CASES.
AND MOBILE CRISIS TEAM STAFFED
BY TRAINED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WHO CAN RESPOND
TO THE COMMUNITY IN THE
COMMUNITY TO CALLERS WHO NEED
TO BE CONNECTED. FROM NINE
EIGHT EIGHT TWO IMMEDIATE
CRISIS SERVICES. WE HAVE
SKYROCKETING RATES OF SUICIDE
AND PEOPLE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
ARE BEING KILLED BY POLICE
EVERY DAY. SUICIDE RATES OVER
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS HAVE GONE
UP 35% AND THE NUMBER IS ONLY
CONTINUING TO RISE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. RECENT REPORTS IN THE
OUR TIME SURE THAN AN AVERAGE
OF THREE PEOPLE A DAY ARE BEING
SHOT AND KILLED BY POLICE. AND
A QUARTER OF OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS ARE PEOPLE WITH KNOWN
MENTAL ILLNESS. NINETY EIGHT
EIGHT IS UNIVERSALLY ACCESSIBLE
LIFESAVING EMERGENCY PHONE
SERVICE. EVERY PERSON THAT I
HAVE TALKED TO ABOUT THIS BILL
HAS HAD A STORY THEY WANT
SHOULD SHARE WITH ME ABOUT HOW
THEY WISH THEY WOULD HAVE HAD
NINE EIGHT EIGHT. IN A MOMENT
OF CRISIS FOR THEM. PARENTS
WHOSE SONS WERE IN MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS AND NEEDED AN
APPROPRIATE EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
FRIENDS WHO NEEDED A COUNSELOR
TO BE CONNECTED WITH URGENTLY.
MY OWN CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE
SEEN THE LIVES OF THEIR SENSE
TAKEN AT THE HANDS OF POLICE
WELL IN MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS.
UNDER AB NINETY EIGHT EVERY
CALIFORNIAN WILL KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE A RESOURCE TO CALL WHEN
THEY OR A LOVED ONE OR FACING
SUICIDAL OR MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS. IT WILL BE AS SIMPLE AS
PICKING UP THE PHONE AND
DIALING NINE EIGHT EIGHT. AND
THIS IS A KEY POINT WE CAN FIND
THIS LIFESAVING INTERVENTION
FOR LITERALLY PENNIES ON THE
DOLLAR. THE NINE EIGHTY P. IS
DESIGNED TO BUILD ON THE
EXISTING NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE CALL
CENTERS. BUILDING OFFICE
EXISTING SYSTEM COUPLED WITH
THE NEW FEDERAL DOLLARS.
INCLUDING AN 85% REIMBURSEMENT
RATE FOR MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS.
WILL KEEP THIS BE LOW FOR PHONE
CUSTOMERS. WELL THE IMPACT ON
YOUR PHONE BILL MIGHT BE
NEGLIGIBLE. THE IMPACT AND
CALIFORNIANS NEEDING MENTAL
HEALTH WILL BE PROFOUND. EVEN
STILL I AM COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT NO MATTER HOW
SMALL THE FEE IS IT NEVER
PLACES AN UNDUE BURDEN ON THOSE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET. AB NINETY EIGHT STATE THE
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WILL BE
EXEMPT FROM PAYING THE FEE. THE
BILL EXCLUDES PREPAID LINES
WHICH ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
USED BY LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
THIS SIMPLE CHANGE CALLING NINE
EIGHT EIGHT INSTEAD OF NINE ONE
ONE WILL HAVE A LASTING IMPACT
ON OUR CONSTITUENTS LIVE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS VITAL AND TIMELY
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. SPEAKING
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS
TERRAKOM TARA CAMPBELL EAST MEN
FROM THE SIGN READING INSTITUTE
AND ANGELA CAMPBELL FROM THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS- THANK YOU JUST THIS
CUSTOMER TO THE COMMITTEE WERE
GONNA LIMITED TO WITNESSES FOR
TWO WITNESSES AGAINST. THE
GENERAL PUBLIC WILL SPEAK- NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY FOR
THOSE MAIN WITNESSES WERE
LIMITING TO TWO MINUTES. I WANT
TO BE FAIR TO EVERYBODY SO I'M
GONNA HAVE TO TREAT EVERYBODY
EQUALLY AND SHUT IT DOWN AFTER
TWO MINUTES. ARE ASKED KILEY
THE DAY HUH WRAP UP. THANK YOU
FOR- THIS GAMBLE EASTMAN BEGIN.
YES THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS THE NATION'S LARGEST
GRASSROOTS MENTAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATION AND OUR STATE
ORGANIZATION ON THE CALIFORNIA
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY. MY NAME IS
ANGELA CAMPBELL AND I'M THE
NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY
AND PUBLIC POLICY AT MOUNT. NOT
HERE GERMAN. HI AT THE END.
ANNOUNCED NINETY DATE WITH
COMING WHY THREE NON FOR MEN
HEALTH OF CRISES. HE SAID
WORKED ON THAT. IN OUR
AMERICANS HER. YOU ARE NOT
ALONE. HOPE OUT THERE AND FILL
IT UP BE THREE DIGITS AWAY.
FOLLOWING A FIFTY ACTIONS NOT
ME A WIDE RANGE OF. INCLUDING
THEM FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION THE NATIONAL FOR
HEALTH AND THE TRACKER FIVE.
CHANGE AT THE TABLE WITH POWER.
IN AND- BOXERS CAN THEY GO THE
NATIONAL FOOTBALL HOT ONE. ACT
TWIN TWENTY. FIVE LET. NOT ONLY
PUT EIGHT EIGHT INSTEAD. IT
PROVIDED THAT FIRST THE BILL
THE CRISIS WITH SYSTEM THAT
WOULD ENSURE A MENTAL RISKS. TO
MENTAL HEALTH. AUTHORIZING
EIGHT EIGHT CHARGES ON TAX OF
ONE. OKAY A QUOTE THE FIFTEENTH
THAT ROUTING OF. SO NOW AND THE
PROVISION THAT MOUNT HOW RIGHT
OUT REACH AND STABILIZE
SERVICES. LANGUAGE AT THE
FOURTH OF CONGRESS BUT THE VOTE
IMPOSED. THE FINE ALLOPATHY
TRUMP. I QUOTE WHAT MAKES WHO
SHOW MENTAL HEALTH WILL BE
FROM. ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS WOULD WRAP IT UP.
THANK YOU- WHAT I NEED THERE'S
A REAL OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE
THE PARADIGM FOR CRISIS
RESPONSE AND IT CAN ONLY HAPPEN
IF IT BY CALIFORNIA IN THAT
NINE NINE EIGHT EIGHT
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE'RE THRILLED.
THAT CALIFORNIA WOULD NEED THAT
PART THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MISS
CAMPBELL PLEASE. MODERATOR
APOLOGIES NO NO PROBLEM
TOMORROW THANK YOU SO MUCH.
INTERCEDE I APOLOGIZE GOOD
pAND MEMBERS ARE AGAIN BY
EVENING WITH THE FEINBERG
INSTITUTE AND WE'RE A VERY
POWERFUL BONSER AT EIGHTY NINE
EIGHT EIGHT THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE HOTLINE DESIGNATION ACT
HAS GIVEN CALIFORNIA AND
UNPRECEDENTED OPPORTUNITY TO
DEVELOP A WEALTH RESTORED
AFFECTIVE AND COMPASSIONATE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM. IT'S TRUE
THAT IF WE FAIL TO PASS EIGHTY
NINE EIGHT EIGHT NOW COME JULY
TWENTY FROM TO THE TEN DIGIT
NUMBER WILL STILL BE A THREE
DIGIT ONE BUT AFTER EXACTLY THE
PROBLEM MAKING THE SWITCH TO
THE EASY TO REMEMBER NUMBER IS
PROJECTED TO DRIVE CALL VOLUMES
UP BY 30% WITHOUT THE NECESSARY
FUNDING AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ADAPT TO BE DEDUCTIBLE CHANGES.
THE THREE DIGIT NUMBER WILL
TRIPLE OUR EXISTING SYSTEM
PEOPLE IN CRISIS WILL SIT ON
HOLD CALLS WILL GO UNANSWERED
DOES THAT MAKE BOTH GET THROUGH
AND EXPECT RESOURCES WILL
RECEIVE NINE AND INSTEAD OF
TRAINED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS RESPONDING. IT
WILL BE LAW ENFORCEMENT. WHEN
SOMEONE ISN'T IT CAN AS HOUR OF
ENERGY TO REACH OUT HELP HAVING
NUMBER THAT IS. STAFFED GREETS
PERSONS BEING FORCED TO JUMP TO
INCLUDE AND CALL NUMBER NUMBER.
THAT CAN BE THE BETWEEN LIFE
DEATH. CALIFORNIA DIDN'T GET TO
THE ON SWITCH NINE EIGHTY. BUT
WE DO GET TO DECIDE HOW WE WILL
RESPOND. THE DECISION WE MAKE
TODAY WILL HAVE LIFE AND DEATH
CONSEQUENCES FOR CALIFORNIANS
ACROSS THE STATE. WHILE
CREATING A TRADEMARK FOR THIS
LEVEL OF REFORM OVER THE NEXT
FIFTEEN MONTHS AS AMBITIOUS. IT
IS NECESSARY TO KEEP OUR MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS SYSTEM AFLOAT AND
IMPROVING TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THOSE MOST VULNERABLE AMONG
THAT. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I BOTH STATUS
TRANSFORMATIONAL PEOPLE PLEDGE
SOLUTION THANK. YOU AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES LIKE TO
START WITH- MERRY JUNE TWO
YEARS- OR IS CAROLINE MCINTYRE.
AVAILABLE MODERATE PLEASE. YOU
MISTER CHEN MEMBERS ENGAGED THE
S. P. ON BEHALF OF FCA'S
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING COUNTY
AND CHRONIC BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS WE'RE GONNA BE
FILLING OPPOSE IN LIKE A MINUTE
POSITION WE'VE HAD POSITIVE
CONVERSATIONS THAT OFTEN
FUNCTIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE
LET'S LEGISLATION WHO CLARIFIED
THAT IT IS ALSO DOING PENSION
SHOULD THAT THE SURCHARGE HE
CAN ALSO BE USED TO FIND.
MOBILE AND W. SERVICES WHICH WE
REQUESTED SUPPORT WE DO STILL
HAVE OUTSTANDING AND QUESTIONS
REGARDING- WE ACTIVE ROLE IN
MANAGING THE OVERALL MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS STRUCTURE
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO THE
ACTUAL DEVELOPMENT AND
PROVISION OF MOBILE CRISIS TEAM
AND CRISIS STABILIZATION
SERVICES IN EACH COUNTY- ALL
THAT SAID YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA
FAN COMMITTED TO MAKING THE
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION TO A
SINGLE PAYER WITH THAT
CONVENTION. AND MENTAL HEALTH
HOTLINES AND EXPANSION OF
LOCALLY AVAILABLE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND CRISIS SERVICES
DELIVERED BY TRAINED AND
SKILLED HONEY. WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY EGGMAN AS WE
FIND RESOLUTION TO MEET WITH
CRIMINALS UNTIL THEN WE ARE IN
AN OPPOSE UNLESS. AMENDED
POSITION THANK YOU. THANK MISS
MY IF YOUR BILL PLEASE THIS
MODERN. FROM OR MATTER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. I CAN
MCINTYRE BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CABLE CAL. THAT THAT. I LET ME
START BY SAYING THAT HE HAD
CABLE INDUSTRY SUPPORTS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE THREE
DIGIT DIALING CODE FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION HOTLINE AND CRISIS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA AS HAS BEEN POINTED
OUT THE FTC HAS ALREADY
REQUIRED ISSUED AN ORDER
REQUIRING THE INDUSTRY TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM AND WE
PLAN TO DO SO BY THE
APPROPRIATE DEADLINE. AT BUT
THIS BILL WOULD IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL SURCHARGE ON THEM
BUT NOT ALL VOICE
COMMUNICATIONS CUSTOMER TO PAY
FOR THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BILL INCLUDING THE COST TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
SERVICES MOBILE CORRECTIVE
SUPPORT TEAMS CRISIS
STABILIZATION SERVICES AND MANY
OTHER ELEMENTS OF CRISIS
INTERVENTION. WHILE THE FCC DID
IN FACT AUTHORIZE THE USE OF
THE THIRD CHARGE IN ORDER TO
THE PUBLIC THE PROGRAM IT DID
NOT REQUIRE IT AND WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THE FUNDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IS AN
APPROPRIATE AND COST DEBT TO BE
FUNDED BY. CONSUMERS PHONE
BILLS. WHEN CONSIDERING WHETHER
TO IMPOSE A NEW CHARGE SUPPORT
THE PRO. YOU SHOULD ALSO. ALL A
THE CHARGES THAT CAL CUSTOMERS
PAY ON THEIR MONTHLY BILLS
WHICH INCLUDE NINE ONE ONE FEES.
AND SIX SURCHARGES TO FIND
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. THE FCC AT THEIR
TARGET THE CPC USER FEE AND
LOCAL UTILITY TAXES. AB NINE
EIGHT EIGHT ATTEMPTS TO MODEL
THE SURCHARGE AFTER THE NINE
ONE ONE THREE BUT THE NINE ONE
ONE FEE DOES NOT PAY FOR POLICE
AND FIRE SERVICE AND THE NINE
EIGHT EIGHT FEET SHOULD NOT PAY
FOR TREATMENT PERMITS AND- AT A
MINIMUM CPPA WOULD REQUEST THAT
A. B. NINE EIGHT EIGHT BE
AMENDED TO LIMIT THE
APPLICATION OF THE THIRD
CHARGE. ONLY THAT HOT THAT IS
RELATED TO THE COMMUNICATION
ASPECT THAT PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
MOVING ALONG TO ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OPPOSITION TESTIMONY-
FROM THE PUBLIC I REMIND YOU
NAME AND POSITION ONLY- AND I
HAVE TO BE FIRM WITH THAT. AND
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
WITNESSES THAT ARE FOUND IN THE
CHAMBERS. I BELIEVE THERE ARE
SOME NAMES NO THEY'RE NOT NAME
AND. AND ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION WITNESSES- IN THE
REMOTE- CENTER. HEARING HEARING
ON ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- VIA PHONE
AGAIN PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
POSITION FOR THIS BILL AB NINE
EIGHT PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. IF YOU'VE BEEN PLACED IN
QUEUE FOR DIFFERENT BILL YOU
MEMBERS MOVE YOURSELF BY
REPEATING THE COMMAND. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN TO NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS WAQAR FIREFOX ALLEN I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT
MANZANITA SERVICES IN YOUR
KAYAK CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT.
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE. THREE THIRTY THREE THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE. LINE
THREE THREE THREE IS YOUR PHONE
ON MUTE. HOME OF THE LINE.
THREE TWELVE THREE ONE TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIE
COLLINS QUIT CONSPECIFIC OR
CENTERS FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES LOCATED IN VENTURA AND
SANTA BARBARA COUNTIES AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE ALIGN THREE THIRTY ONE
THREE THREE ONE. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THERE ARE FLOCKS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA.
HEALTH NETWORK OKAY YEAH THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR THE LINE. TO
SEVENTY ONE TWO SEVEN ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS CALLS
WORSE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
THREE OH THREE THREE ZERO THREE.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALICIA WELCOME
AND I'M WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH
ASSOCIATION OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETY EIGHT. NEXT OF MINE.
THREE FORTY NINE THREE FOUR
NINE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS
IS WENDY **** REPRESENTING
HALFWAY SYCAMORES BASED IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE EIGHT EIGHT. OVER A THREE
FORTY FIVE THREE FOUR FIVE I
GET IT. THANK THANK YOU FOR
COMING WITH THE L. A. COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HOW CO
SPONSOR OF EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT AND WE'D URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. LINE. TO NINETY SIX
TWO NINE SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON THAT SO I
MEET AS ON BEHALF OF THE TRI
VALLEY CITIES OF DUBLIN
LIVERMORE PLEASANTON SAN RAMON
AND THE TOWN OF DANVILLE AS
WELL AS THE CITY TO SIGN PAULO
CONCORD LAW FIRE AND WALNUT
CREEK IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE.
THREE SIXTY TWO THREE SIX TWO.
THAT AFTERNOON THAT SEARCH TERM
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
NINE THREE SIXTY FIVE THREE SIX
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU DON'T FROM
THE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS
AND CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. TO SEVENTY TWO TWO
SEVEN TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
POKING UP ON BEHALF OF EVERY
TOWN FOR GUN SAFETY AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE THREE ZERO FIVE
THREE HUNDRED FIVE. H. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR TOO BAD
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS AND
SUPPORT. LIME. THREE FIFTY
THREE THREE FIVE THREE.
STANDING UP FOR WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA SILLY AT THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS ALSO MUST NOT BE
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS. LINE. TWO FIFTY NINE
TWO FIVE NINE. HELLO THIS IS
MAYOR KEVIN WILL COME WHEN THE
CREEK CALIFORNIA I WON WITH THE
CITY FULLY SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE
EIGHT EIGHT MCCARTY STOCK.
THANK YOU. LINE. THREE SEVENTY
ONE THREE SEVEN ONE. THIS IS
YOUR MEMBERS THIS IS MARK
BISHOP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCY NUMBER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT WITH AN
AMENDMENT AND THANK THE AUTHOR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US.
BLIND. TWO SEVENTY TWO SEVEN
ZERO. HI THIS IS WARREN THANK
YOU FOR COUNTY FARM APPROXIMATE
BONTA THAT AB NINE A AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE. TWO
SEVENTY FIVE TWO SEVEN FIVE. BY
DESIGN ADAM STATEMENT
REPRESENTING JOHN CARPENTER
WITH TROOPS LOVE JUSTICE AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. FINE. TO
EIGHTY TWO EIGHT ZERO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS TYLER
BEEN BE RECOUNTED A HIP HOP
TRACTORS APPROPRIATION WE HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF AMANDA POSITION
AND APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS CONVERSATION TODAY
THANK YOU. NINE THREE TWENTY
ONE THREE TWO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BEN
EIGHTY ON BEHALF OF WALL SPACE
HEALTH A CALIFORNIA ISSUE ASIDE
PREVENTION CRISIS CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT NINE EIGHT
EIGHT. LINE TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
TWO EIGHT SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SUSAN BALI I AM A MOTHER
AND GRANDMOTHER THANK YOU FOR
CALL. I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
EIGHT NINE EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE
VOTE YES THANK YOU. LINE. TWO
FIVE SEVEN TO FIFTY SEVEN.
ARAMBULA BEHALF OF CTIA THE
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY AND WE ARE
OPPOSED IN LESS AMENDED TO A.
B. NINE EIGHTY. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE SIXTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER MICHELLE
THOMAS SHOP REPRESENTING THAT
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. TWO EIGHTY ONE TWO
EIGHT ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS
CRAIG CAMPBELL SEEN I'M A
VOLUNTEER FOR MOMS DEMAND
ACTION FOR GUN SENSE CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHTY NINE
EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU. LIME.
THREE EIGHTY TWO THREE EIGHT
TWO. JOHN VAN OVER AND BEHALF
OF DVSA THE DEPRESSION BIPOLAR
SUPPORT ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORTER BUT OUT OF
IT BUT THANK YOU. BY AM THREE
THIRTY EIGHT THREE THREE EIGHT.
HELLO MY NAME IS JIM TAT HE
CAN I'M FROM SURGE SHOWING UP
FOR RACIAL JUSTICE SACRAMENTO
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. NINE
EIGHT EIGHT. WELL I AM. THREE
THIRTY THREE THREE ZERO. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YEAH YES. MY
NAME IS LAURIE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MY NAME IS LAURIE WALL I'M
A VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION FOR GUN SENSE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE EIGHT EIGHT
THREE PRO YES THANK YOU. NEXT
WE HAVE LINE. TWO EIGHTY NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE. HELLO MY NAME
THE SHANK FINISHING ME I AM
FROM THAT MENTAL HEALTH IS THE
VISION OF ALAMEDA COUNTY AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB NINE EIGHT
EIGHT. I DON'T. NINE THREE
THIRTY NINE THREE THREE NINE.
HIGHLINE THREE THIRTY NINE ANY
OTHER. WE'LL GO TO LINE. THREE
SIXTEEN THREE SIX ZERO. HI MY
NAME IS MICHELLE WETLAND IN
CHINO HILLS ON THE VOLUNTEER
CRISIS COUNSELOR WITH CRISIS
TEXT LINE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE EIGHT EIGHT
CLEAN BUT YES. LINE. TWO FORTY
NINE TWO FOUR NINE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DR CORINNE
MCINTOSH TACO AND I'M FROM THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
MOBILE LIFE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
COALITION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINE EIGHT EIGHT WITHOUT
AMENDMENT PLEASE VOTE YEAH.
THANK YOU. LINE. TWO FIFTY SIX
TWO FIVE SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER ADRIN
SHELTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE THE CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES SUPPORTED EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT THANKS. BLIND. TWO
FIFTY FOUR TWO FIVE FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY. LINE. TWO SIXTY FOUR
TWO SIX FOUR. HI MY NAME'S
KATHERINE JONES I'M A VOLUNTEER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN
SENSE IN AMERICA AND I AM IN
THE PORT OF EIGHTY NINE EIGHT
EIGHT THANK YOU. NEXRAD LINE.
TO NINETY THREE TWO NINE THREE.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANIL HE SAID
THAT HER LAN L. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE VOTE YES. THANK
YOU. LINE. THREE SIXTY SEVEN
THREE SIX SEVEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE REOPEN FROM WHAT I
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB NINE EIGHT EIGHT
PLEASE VOTE YES. LINE. THREE
EIGHTEEN THREE ONE EIGHT. HI MY
NAME'S KRISTA MAGAR I'M FROM
WALNUT CREEK I STRONGLY SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINE EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE
VOTE YES ON. NINE TWO SIX THREE
TWO SIXTY THREE. HELLO THIS IS
CATHERINE WALLY AND RESIDENT OF
WILL AND WILL NOT TREAT CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE
EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE VOTE YES.
THANK YOU. GOING. TO FIFTY
SEVEN TWO FIVE SEVEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS DONNA BERRY I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT YES. NINE THREE ZERO SIX
THREE OH SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS
ASHLEY TRêN AND ON BEHALF OF
YOUR TYPE PREVENTION SERVICE OF
THE CENTRAL COAST MECHANICS
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINETY. THANK YOU. CLIMB.
TO SIXTY SIX TWO SIX SIX. HELLO
MY NAME IS OUT OF LINE WITH THE
CURRENT PROJECTS AND PRODUCT OF
THE WTO CALIFORNIA HE STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE EIGHT EIGHT
THE BOOK AT THANK YOU. WINE.
TWO FIFTY THREE TWO FIVE THREE.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR AND BECAUSE
OF HIM LOOMIS ON BEHALF OF
CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS
ALIGNING OURSELVES WITH AS THE
CTA'S OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AT
THE MONEY THANK YOU. BRIAN.
THREE SIXTY ONE THREE SIX ONE.
MAN THIS IS JENNIFER ALLEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE TO
SIXTY NINE TWO SIX NINE. HI MY
NAME'S JOHN WALL AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE MOUSE
OFF THAT WE ARE ALSO A CO
SPONSORS AND ON THE FLIGHT PUT
FEEDING BILL- WOULD HAVE MADE
MY FRIENDS WHAT ORGANIZATIONS.
HE'S YOU. THANK YOU. THREE
THREE NINETY ONE THREE NINE
ONE. HELLO STACEY HERE A MODEL
FOR RAMCO THE RACIAL AND ETHNIC
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE. TO NINETY ONE
TWO NINE ONE. BUT I NEED TO
MAKE A WHOLE I STRONGLY SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
CLICK HERE. LIME. THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT THREE EIGHT EIGHT. MY
NAME IS TRINA WITH ME THE STUDY
IN ACTION AND SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE MY STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE EIGHT EIGHT
PLEASE VOTE YES. WELL I AM.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THREE SEVEN
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER NUMBERS
CAME FROM SMALL TO HEAR ABOUT
THE FOUNTAIN HOUSE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINE EIGHT EIGHT.
THANK YOU. LINE. THREE THIRTY
FIVE THREE THREE FIVE. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHERYL WHITE- I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH DIGNITY AND
POWER NOW AND I'M ALSO THE
PARTNER WITH INCOME LOOKING
BACK CHILDREN TWIN TOWERS- WE
ARE STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY PLEASE PRACTICE THANK
YOU. LIME. THREE NINETY NINE
THREE NINE NINE. HI MY NAME IS
LAURA HARTMAN I'M
REPRESENTATIVE FOR EMPOWER EACH
CHANGE AND WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. LINE FOR ALL
ONE FOUR ZERO ONE. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES. HI THIS IS
DONNA HERNANDEZ WITH SOUTHEAST
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION AND WE'RE STRONG
SUPPORTER OF- OF THE WORD
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU KNOW
OTHER LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. ARE GOING TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOING
TO CAN QUESTIONS FROM CAYMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS APOLOGIZE ON
THAT'S GOT STUCK. YES I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING%
THIS FORWARD I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANYBODY ON THE FLOOR OR
IN OUR COMMUNITIES WHO HAVEN'T
BEEN TOUCHED BY MENTAL ILLNESS
IN THEIR LIVES. AND HAVING A
HOT LINE LIKE NINE EIGHT WILL
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED SERVICES
FOR OUR COMMUNITY. AT THE SAME
TIME I'M REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE SURCHARGE AND WHAT THING
HOW WE ARE CONSISTENT AND WHAT
SURCHARGES COVER- SO CAN THE
AUTHOR DESCRIBES- WHAT- COVER
BY THE SURCHARGE AND WHAT'S
COVERED BY COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH- AND OTHER PROVISIONS-
BECAUSE IN MY MIND IT'S ALMOST
LIKE. TWO BILLS AND ONE WHICH
IS WHAT WE NEED YOU KNOW I
THINK YOU ACKERMAN SAID IN YOUR
OPENING. THAT WITHOUT THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN THE
CRISIS CARE UNITS. IT YOU KNOW
JUST A HOT LINE ITSELF IS NOT
GOING TO GET THE CARE OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED- BUT I REALLY
STRONGLY FEEL TAT A SURCHARGE
SHOULD BE USED FOR THE
PREVENTION OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ON THE GROUND. FOR THE
AUTHOR TO SPEAK TO THAT YES
THANK YOU MISTER NUMBER BACK.
AND SO LET ME SERVICES SO. THAT
THE FEDERAL LEGISLATION WITH
PROVISION IN THERE BECAUSE I
THINK IT ACTUALLY RELATES TO
SOMETHING THAT WAS SAID BY THE
CABLE INDUSTRY- IT ALLOWS FOR
US TO. AND SHE WAS CORRECTED
ALLOWS IT DOESN'T MANDATE US TO
CHARGE A FEE OBVIOUSLY- FOR THE
PROVISION OF OBVIOUSLY THE
OVERALL- TELEPHONE SERVICES IN
THE HOT LINES AS YOU
UNDERSTAND. BUT ALSO FOR
PERSONNEL IN THE PROVISION OF
ACUTE MENTAL HEALTH. CRISIS OUT
REGION STABILIZATION SERVICES.
BY DIRECTING- THE NINETY EIGHT
NATIONAL SUICIDE VENTUREON TO
JUST THREE THINGS WHICH ARE.
THE CRISIS RESPONSE TEAMS
STABILIZATION SERVICES. AND THE
PERSONALITY ANSWER THE PHONE SO
IT'S NOT AND OTHER THINGS SHE
SAID. AND WE ARE WORKING TO
CLARIFY THAT IT IS JUST THE
THINGS IN THE AUTHORIZING
LEGISLATION AND AGAIN JUST THE
SERVICES YOU GOT WHEN YOU PICK
UP THAT PHONE. AND YOU CALL
NINE EIGHT EIGHT RIGHT NOW MANY
PEOPLE IN MENTAL CRISIS.
CALLING ON AND THEY NEED
SOMEONE TO SHOW UP. I SO POLICE
SHOT. AND WE WANT HERE IS FROM
HEALTH PROFESSIONALSTO SHOW UP
AND RIGHT NOW MANY COUNTIES
DON'T HAVE THAT ABILITY AND SO
WE HAVE TO SET THAT UP WITH IT
INTO A WELL AS I MENTIONED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL COVER
85% OF THAT IS A FEDERAL
MATCHING 85% SO THAT IS DOES
TAKE THAT COSTS DOWN BUT IT
DOES JUST PROVIDE THE SERVICES
ARE ACTUALLY PROVIDED IN
CONJUNCTION WITH NINETY EIGHT
EIGHT. BUT I WILL ALSO LET TARA
GIMBEL EASTMAN COMMENT OKAY SHE
HAS ANYTHING TO ADD. FROM THE
START AGAINST YOU. YEAH I KNOW
I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
AND ADDS THAT AND YOU BOTH
HEARD FROM MATTHEW AND- THE
CABLE. EDUCATION AND- AND
COMPLETE EACH DAY. WERE IN
ACTIVE NEGOTIATIONS TO DRAW
THOSE REALLY FINE LINE. ABOUT
WHAT SHOULD BE COVERED AND WHAT
NEEDS TO BE SHARED AND- YOU
KNOW I THINK THOSE BRIGHT LINE
CAN BE DRAWN VERY CLEARLY SO.
THAT SHOULD BE COMING SHORTLY.
I WILL ALSO JUST NOW BECAUSE
THE COMPARISON HAS COME UP TO
NINE ONE ONE. THERE IS NO
REALLY CLEAR FEDERAL GUIDANCE
IN HOW NINE ONE ONE SHE
REVENUE. AND CALIFORNIA NATIVE
BERRY AT THE FIFTH EXPOSITION.
TO LIMIT THE NINE ONE ONE G.
REVENUE TO BEING USED FOR
TECHNOLOGY. BUT THAT'S NOT THE
CASE AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
CALIFORNIA IN MANY WAYS HAS.
BEEN REALLY PROACTIVE IN MAKING
SURE THAT YOU REVENUE. GOES TO
THERAPY NINE ONE ONE. BUT EVEN
HERE WE'VE MADE EXCEPTIONS
REVIEWS NINE ONE ONE THREE
REVENUE FOR WILDFIRE MITIGATION
WHICH MEANS ENTIRELY%
APPROPRIATE. AND HERE BECAUSE
THERE WAS SUCH A SPECIFIC
VISION FOR HOW. THE NINE EIGHT
EIGHT SYSTEM WOULD BE SET UP.
CONGRESS DIDN'T LEAVE IT OPEN
AND IT LIKE THEY DID WITH NINE
ONE ONE. THEY WERE VERY
SPECIFIC ABOUT IT COVERING THE
SCORE THING. THE ROUTING CALL
PERSONAL MOBILECRISIS AND
CRISIS. CRISIS STABILIZATION
SERVICES. AND SO. WHILE THERE
ARE CERTAINLY SIMILARITIES TO
NINE ONE ONE THEY- ARE
INCREDIBLY DISTINCT AND I
THINK. WHAT WE REALLY HAVE TO
FOCUS ON ATHLETES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THAT IS THAT. BOTTOM
LINE THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE.
THAT WHEN YOU PICK UP THE PHONE
YOU HAVE ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH. SERVICES SHE WOULD
NEVER CALL NINE ONE ONE WITH A
HEART ATTACK AND BE TOLD THAT
THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO HELP
OUR CALL WITH THE FIRE IN YOUR
HOUSE AND TOLD NO ONE IS THERE
TO HELP. YOU THINK WE NEED TO
REMEMBER. THAT IF HE IS REALLY
SERVING A CRITICAL PIECE. OF
THE PUZZLE IN MAKING. SURE THAT
THE SIMPSONS TOGETHER. SO WITH
I DO. THAT THAT IS THE PER. OF
THE SPA OF THE- I WOULD SAY IS
LET. THE A- THAT NINE ONE WAS
NEARLY. AND I THINK IT'S ABOUT
WHO BEARS THE COST FOR
PROVISION OF SERVICES. AND WE
SHOULD THAT BE YOUR MOBILE
PROVIDERS- MOBILE REPAIRS. OR
SHOULD THAT BE THE GOVERNMENT
AND SO I THINK THERE'S MORE
WORK TO DO AND I WOULD LOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR OF THE SPONSORS TO HELP
THREAD THAT NEEDLE- BECAUSE I'M
VERY CONCERNED THAT IF WE DON'T
SOLVE THIS AND WE STILL
COMBINED. PROVISION OF ON THE
GROUND SERVICES WITH THE
SURCHARGE THIS IS SOMETHING I
COULDN'T SUPPORT ON THE FLOOR.
BUT I KNOW YOU'RE IN THESE
ACTIVE NEGOTIATIONS AND I
APPRECIATE THAT SO I'LL GIVE A
COURTESY I TODAY. AND LOOK FOR
TO THOSE CONTINUE NEGOTIATIONS
THE OTHER POINT I REALLY LIKE
TO THINK THE AUTHORED ABOUT THE
CAP. YOU KNOW I THINK THAT CAP
IS REALLY IMPORTANT- AND SO
THAT'S WHY THEY IT REALLY
DELINEATING OUT WHAT THE
SURCHARGE WILL COVER. WILL SET
THAT WILL TELL US ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT. THIRTY FORTY
FIFTY CENTS. PER MONTH ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT TEN FIFTEEN CENTS
A MONTH AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AND THE
DISCUSSION AS WELL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AS FOR HER. AFTER
THANK YOU MISTER ROGERS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SOMEONE FRAUD
DURING THIS. PRISON LEGISLATURE
ON PROBABLY A COLD. QUARTERS
WELL. AS SOMEONE MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS EXPERIENCE OF THE
FOR SPOTTER OF SEEING THE NEED
FOR DEDICATED SYSTEMS. TO
PROCESS AND SERVE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCIES. I BELIEVE IT'S
CRUCIAL THIS TIME NOW THE
CALIFORNIA HAS A PROPER
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THE- BEST SERVE THOSE IN
CRISIS. WITHOUT THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE HOW BILL THINKS
CRITICALLY ABOUT HAVING THE
NINE EIGHT EIGHT AND NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEMS WORK TOGETHER. TO
HELP TO RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES.
BUT WITHOUT I DO HAVE A
QUESTION THE HOPEFULLY THE
STEINBERG IT'S TO CAN. HELP
ANSWER- I SAW THE ANSWER ON THE
NOW WITH THAT. REQUIRE IN
OPERABILITY BETWEEN THE NINE
EIGHT EIGHT AND NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEMS WHAT INCREASE THAT NINE
ONE ONE FEE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE OF IS THAT CORRECT IS THAT
FROM THE START LOOKING AT.
KAMALA THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU
ACTUALLY WE EXPECT THE EXACT
OPPOSITE AND IN OUR DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE CALL CENTER AT THE END
WITH THE- YEAH WE UNDERSTAND
THAT BECAUSE THERE'S-
TECHNOLOGY- TRANSFORMATION
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW WITH NEXT
GEN NINE ONE LINE ACTUALLY
LEVERAGING THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
NINE ONE ONE IF YOU THINK FOUR
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT PEOPLE
MASSIVELY STREAMLINE THE COST
THING KEEPING BOTH FEET DOWN-
AND KEEPING PROTOCOLS AND
SYSTEMS THAT STREAMLINE THE
COPPEL AGAIN STREAMLINING THAT
COSTS. WE BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
THE CRITICAL MOMENT TO PUT
NINETY EIGHT FORD AND. HAVE
THAT INTEGRATION. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR ME.
ANYTHING QUESTION BY COMMITTING.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSELY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC I'M IN HEALTH
COMMITTEE. YES HALL WHO IS THE
MOTHER OF MILES HALL WAS ON AS
ONE OF MY WITNESSES AND SHE'S
REALLY WHAT BROUGHT THIS IDEA
TO ME IN THE FIRST PLACE SHE
LOST HER SON- IN MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS TO THE- TO GUNFIRE BY.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AFTER SHE
CALLED FOR HELP. AND IT WAS SO
CLEAR TO ME THAT WE HAD FAILED
THIS MOTHER. AND I KNEW WE HAD
TO DO BETTER AND WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO BETTER AND TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE THAT ARE
CRISIS GET THE RESPONSE THEY
DESERVE. AND THAT MEANS THE 25%
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE. INVOLVED IN
THESE OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS BUT IT ALSO MEANS.
THE 30% OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING ON OUR STREETS AND
HOUSES BECAUSE THEY'RE IN
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS AND I KNOW
THIS IS AN ISSUE THE CHAIR HAS
WORKED ON DEEPLY HOMELESSNESS.
AND WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE PROVIDE WRAP AROUND SERVICES
FOR THOSE THAT ARE SUFFERING
FROM MENTAL ILLNESS SO THEY'RE
ABLE TO GET THE CARE THEY NEED
AND LIVE WITH DIGNITY AND THIS
IS A HUGE STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION AND SO WITH ALL OF
THAT AFTER I. THINK YOU ALSO
NOTICING THE PRESENCE OF A
QUORUM. MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SANTIAGO I'M
HERE. PATTERSON BONAVA.
CERVANTES DAVIES. EDUARDO
GARCIA HOLDEN LOW COOK SILVA.
RODRIGUEZ. HELLO THERE IS.
BENNETT TAKING. FOR THIS BILL
DOES ENJOY A DO PASSED THE
COMMITTEE AND APPROPRIATIONS WE
WOULD NEED A FIRST AND SECOND.
SECOND MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL ROLE. MOTIONS TO PASTA
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATION
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I
PATTERSON. BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I CERVANTES
DAVIES. DAVIS NOT VOTING
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN LOW COKE
SILVA. QUICKSILVER I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ SIGNED VALLADARES.
FELLA THERE'S NOT VOTING SENATE.
SENATE I TAKING. FIVE TWO ZERO
MEASURES ON CALL FIVE ZERO
MAYES ON CALL MISTER GIBSON A.
B. FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT- ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE AND URGE-
EQUITY- MEASURE. APPROXIMATELY
40% OF ALL RESIDENTIAL UNITS IN
PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
COMPLEX ARE NOT CONNECTED TO
THE INTERNET. BOTH PUBLIC
HOUSING RESIDENTS EXPRESSLY
STUDENTS FAMILIES LACK DEVICE
APPROPRIATE FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING AND- TELEHEALTH WHEN
IT COMES TO STUDENTS OF COLOR.
WHO JUST HAPPEN TO LIVE IN
PUBLIC HOUSING. ARE NOT
CONNECTED TO THE INTERNET
EXPRESSLY DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
HAS BECAUSE LEARNING LOS. AS
YOU KNOW LEARNING LOSS REFERS
TO LOSS OF KNOWLEDGE SKILLS OR
REVERSE IN ACADEMIC PROGRESS
DUE TO EXTENDED GAPS IN A
STUDENT'S EDUCATION. THERE IS
SUBSTANTIAL LEARNING LOS
EXPRESSLY IN EARLY GRADES FROM
OUR FOURTH GRADE THROUGH TENTH
GRADE GRADERS IN BOTH ENGLISH A
LEARNING ARTS AND MATH. EQUALLY
IMPORTANT THIS PANDEMIC HAS
CAUSED DISRUPTION IN SCHOOLING
FOR CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES HAVING TO BE HAVING
DISPROPORTIONATE AFFECTS LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND- ENGLISH
LEARNING STUDENTS. THIS
PANDEMIC THROUGH NO FAULT OF
OUR OWN HAS IMPOSED AN EXTENDED
GAP IN THE EDUCATION OF
CALIFORNIA SIX MILLION K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS. HOW.
WILL WE RESPOND AS A
LEGISLATURE WE JOINED
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IS TO IMPROVE
INTERNET ACCESS. IN SOME CASES
DEVICES SO THAT STUDENTS COULD
LEARN. THE QUESTION HERE TODAY
IS WHAT WILL WE WHAT WHAT OUR
RESPONSE BE FAR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES WHO'VE JOINED- JESS-
HAPPEN TO LIVE IN PUBLIC
HOUSING. THE QUESTION IS DO WE
HAVE TO CALIFORNIANS. ONE
CALIFORNIA WHO DO NOT LIVE IN
PUBLIC HOUSING AND THE OTHER.
CALIFORNIANS WHO DO LIVE IN
PUBLIC HOUSING. AB. TWENTY FIVE
ONE FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE SIX TO
ENSURE THAT ALL LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS OF PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING HAVE ACCESS TO N. CAN
USE HIGH SPEED INTERNET
BROADBAND SERVICE THE MISSION
TO SUPPORT DISTANCE LEARNING.
TELE HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY
TO ASSIST THEM IN GETTING OUT
OF POVERTY. MY BILL A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE IST COPIES
A COMPLIMENTARY AB FOURTEEN.
AND SENATE BILL FOUR BY
GONZALEZ AND AGUIAR-CURRY IT'S
TRANSFERRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND PUBLIC HOUSING FUND AND
SET A GOAL TO CONNECT ALL
RESIDENTS BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. ORDERS SOONER IF POSSIBLE
THIS IS NOT GENERAL FUND MONEY
LET ME UNDERSCORE THIS IS NOT
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS IT IS
CURRENTLY- TELECOM SURCHARGE.
THESE FUNDS GO TO GRANTS TO
CONNECT RESIDENTS. AND PROVIDE
ACCESS TO PUBLIC HOUSING IN
BOTH UNDERSCORE BOTH RURAL AND
URBAN COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
THOSE WHO WORK IN OUR FARMS. TO
PRODUCE OUR FOOD. FINALLY AB
TWENTY I MEAN A. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE FOCUSED ON THREE
ESSENTIAL COMPONENTS ONE
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY. IN THEIR
HOUSING UNITS TO COMPUTER
DEVICES TO MEET THEIR NEEDS
THREE DIGITAL LITERACY LITERACY
PROFICIENCY TO USE THE
TECHNOLOGIES- TO SAVE TIME AND
MONEY. THESE THREE COMPONENTS
CONNECTIVITY DEVICE DIGITAL
LITERACY ARE THREE GOALS OF THE
CALIFORNIA BROADBAND COUNCIL.
IS PART OF THEIR PLAN ACTION
FOR ALL. I AM AWARE THAT OTHER
BILLS HAVE SOME OF THE SAME
COMPONENTS NOT APPLAUD THOSE
EFFORTS. I AM HAPPY TO KEEP THE
LINES OF COMMUNICATION OPEN
ADVOCATES THAT SHARE MY GOALS
BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
THREE COMPONENTS MUST BE PART
OF THIS BILL. BUT AS A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA BROADBAND
COUNCIL WHO WORK HARD TO MAKE
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
BROADBAND FOR ALL. UP
ACTIONABLE THESE THREE.
COMPONENTS ARE CENTRAL TO THIS
BILL ONCE AGAIN CONNECTIVITY'S
DEVICE DIGITAL LITERACY. WE
CAN'T HAVE A BILL WITHOUT THESE
THREE COMPONENTS WE CAN WE CAN
NOT HAVE THE CALIFORNIA. A
CALIFORNIA THAT'S CONNECTED AND
ONE CALIFORNIA THAT'S
DISCONNECTED. I AM CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION CONTINUALLY
REACHING OUT AND WILL DO SO AND
COMMIT MYSELF TODAY TO- SIT
DOWN WITH THE CALIFORNIA CABLE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION.
AND COMMIT TO WORKING TO TRY TO
FIND- A MIDDLE GROUND THAT WE
CAN ALL RAPPER ARMS AROUND AND
HOPEFULLY REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION HERE WERE THREE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
FOR FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE IS MY
STUDY- MAKE PETE CALIFORNIA
MERGING TECHNOLOGY FUND AND
ALSO SAYS ALL MONTH- FROM THE
NEW START HOUSING CORPORATION
IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE. THEY'RE WITH US IN PERSON.
AND MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
JUST BRING COMMITTEES TENSION
THIS IS MY DISTRICT AND THE RED
DOTS REPRESENT THE PUBLIC
HOUSING THAT IN MY DISTRICT.
REFERENCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER GETS WILL PROCEED TO THE
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH
STARTING WITH- MISMATCH- THIS
BUT PEAK IF YOU'RE ON AND-
MICELLE TOMORROW SORRY MR
MONSEF YOU'RE ON. IT CHAIRMAN
SANTIAGO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M I'M HERE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU WE
BEGIN BY COMMENDING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON FOR THE COURAGE
AND THE VISION TO BRING FORWARD
AB. FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. YOU
HEARD ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
TALK ABOUT 40% OF THE RESIDENTS
IN PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
NOT BEING CONNECTED. THAT IS
FROM SURVEYS THAT WERE DONE
ABOUT A YEAR AGO. THE FOR THE
PANDEMIC SHELTER IN PLACE. AT
THAT POINT WE HAD A SITUATION
IN WHICH THE MAJORITY OF
RESIDENTS IN PUBLICLY
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING COULD NOT BE
CONNECTED CONTINUOUSLY THEIR
CHILDREN COULDN'T CONNECT FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING AND THEY
COULDN'T ACCESS THEIR DOCTORS
FOR VISITS. YOU HAVE BEEN A
CHAMPION MISTER CHAIRMAN
BECAUSE AS I HOLD HERE A LIST
OF MORE THAN FIFTY SIX HUNDRED
PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
COMPLEXES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YOU HAVE MORE THAN
ANYONE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBER
OF THE ASSEMBLY SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SENSITIVITY TO
THESE RESIDENTS AND- APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU HAVE ALWAYS DONE OVER
THE YEARS TO SUPPORT THEM. THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT THE
PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
COMPLEXES. OR ON A FIXED BUDGET
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE ABILITY
WITHOUT OUR HELP. TO GET THE
CONNECTIVITY THE DIGITAL
LITERACY TRAINING OR THE
DEVICES FOR THEIR RESIDENTS.
THERE RESIDENTS ARE ALSO THE
MOST IMPOVERISHED CALIFORNIANS
IN OUR STATE BY DEFINITION.
THIS IS THE TIME IN WHICH WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO REACH OUT.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH INDUSTRY.
WITH THE PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING COMPLEXES THESE ARE THE
HOUSING AUTHORITIES ON BY THE
GOVERNMENT AND ALSO NONPROFIT
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS TO WORK
IN PARTNERSHIP TO GET EVERYONE
CONNECTED. AS WE'VE COME TO
UNDERSTAND DIGITAL ACCESS IS
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY CIVIL
RIGHTS AND ACCESS DELAYED IS
ACCESS DENIED IT IS TIME THAT
WE GET ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
ESPECIALLY OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION ONLINE THANK YOU.
MISTER MARKS. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS A CAESAR SALAD WHAT
MONTH I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF NEW START HOUSING
AND- TIMERS HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION WERE A- NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION DEVELOPMENT A
SERVING LOW COST LOW INCOME
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE BECAUSE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET AND OUR HOUSING
FACILITY IS NOT A LUXURY IT'S A
NECESSITY. WHEN THE PANDEMIC
STARTED MANY OF OUR FAMILIES IN
OUR HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR UNIT
COMPLEX IN HUNTINGTON PARK. AND
IT EIGHTY FOUR UNITS IN CHINO.
WERE AFFECTED BY THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO INTERNET SERVICE.
ACCESS TO COMPUTERS. AND ACCESS
TO BASIC DIGITAL LITERACY
TRAINING. BASED ON RECENT
SURVEYS 89% OF OUR RESIDENTS
WERE NOT CONNECTED. 89% MANY OF
OUR KIDS COULD NOT ACCESS THEIR
CLASSROOM ONLINE AND THEIR
PARENTS COULD NOT AFFORD ACCESS
TO BROADBAND. THIS BILL AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE WHEN SURE
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY TO ALL
RESIDENTIAL UNITS AND PROVIDE
DIGITAL LITERACY TRAINING FOR
RESIDENTS. AND ASSIST THEM IN
GETTING APPROPRIATE COMPUTING
DEVICES. WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO
HINDER OUR KIDS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WITH LACK OF BROADBAND
ACCESS IT SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO ALL EVEN THOSE RESIDING IN
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING. OUR
RESIDENTS IN SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
ARE BY DEFINITION THE POOREST
CALIFORNIANS AND MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY IS
ESSENTIAL FOR DISTRICT
DISDAINFULLY TELEHEALTH REMOTE
WORK JOB TRAINING AND
EMPLOYMENT APPLICATIONS PLEASE
I URGE YOU TO HELP OUR
RESIDENTS BY SUPPORTING AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE A POSE UNLESS
AMENDED- IS MCINTYRE I BELIEVE
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CAROLYN
MCINTYRE ON BEHALF THAT THE
EPA- FIRST OF ALL LET ME STATE
THAT WE ARE VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THE OBJECTIVE AS AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. AND WE
ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE FAMILY MEMBER
GETS SENT TO SIMPLY WORK OUT
SOME OF THE ASPECTS OF THE
LANGUAGE BUT WE ARE VERY MUCH
ALIGNED. WITH THE OBJECTIVES
THAT THE BILL THANK YOU. HI
THINKING. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
ANY ADDITIONAL- SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WITNESSES BUT I WILL
STATE FOLLOWING- WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS IT'S TYPICAL CUSTOM
OF THE HOUSE TO- TO LIMIT WHEN
WE HAVE A NEXT MEETING TO UNDER
COLD BUT I GOT IT WE GOT A
TERMINATE SOME POINT IN TIME SO
THE NEXT THING COMES IN SO
WE'RE LIMIT ALL COMMENTS TO. A
TOTAL OF THIRTY MINUTES FOR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THAT INCLUDES-
LET ME FINISH THIS ARTICLE
INCLUDES- IT INCLUDES- ME TO
USE FOR OR AGAINST A TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE TIME TO
HEAR ALL BILLS TODAY- AS I
MENTIONED WILL BE ANOTHER-
COMMITTEE MEETING- DURING THE
CHAMBER AFTER US PLEASE- FOR
THIS PORTION OF IT YOU'LL STATE
YOUR- NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ONLY I DID NOT HAVE
LISTED HERE AND ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION WITNESS- I DID. I DO
NOT HAVE LISTED HERE IN
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION WITNESS.
BUT I DON'T HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED
HERE. SO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON- TO THE ME TOOS.
WE'RE GOING TO STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY-
AND WILL CONTINUE- SILVA FIRST
BEGAN IN THE CHAMBERS. I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN IN THE CHAMBER
WITH ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ONLY. HI MY NAME IS PAUL
MCGOVERN FROM WHY AMERICA WE'RE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF GOOD
CONNECTIONS OF BROADBAND FOR
EVERYONE WE WOULD LIKE TO BE
THE PRIMARY OPPOSITION SPEAKER
TO THIS BILL SO YOU COULD
UNDERSTAND HOW TO AMEND IT AND
MAKE IT EVEN BETTER. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR NAY WIENER THAT
ADDITION ORGANIZATION ONLY
THANK YOU WILL BE GOING ON IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL. ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
CHAMBER. ADAM WILL CONTINUE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OPPOSITION
AND THE- REMOTE STATION. THEN
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON- BY
PHONE- MODERATOR AND NOTING
THAT WE HAVE TO THIRTY MINUTES
FOR ALL TOTAL. YOU TO STATE
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE ME
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE'LL
START WITH LINE. TO FIFTY FOUR
TWO FIVE FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THE NEXUS LINE. FOR FOURTEEN
FOR ONE FOR. GOOD AFTERNOON
PICK ME FAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TWO EIGHTY SIX TWO EIGHT SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOB BRADLEY
LEGACY GARDEN RESIDENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. BLIND. FOR
THIRTEEN FOR ONE THREE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAX
PERRY ON THE HALF OF THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH ALSO IN SUPPORT.
LINE. TWO SIXTY THREE TWO SIX
THREE. LINE TWO SIXTY THREE ARE
YOU WANT ME. STE HELLO THIS IS
CATHERINE WYLIE RESIDENT OF
WALNUT CREEK I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE. LINE FOR TWELVE OR ONE
TO. HELLO THIS IS JACKSON LOOP
ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT HOUSING IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. NEXT
IN LINE FOR ALL THREE OR. THREE
FIND FOR ALL THREE OF YOUR
DEVICE MUTED. WE'LL GO TO LINE.
FOR SIXTEEN FOR ONE SIX. FOR
SIXTEEN OR YOU WANT ME. WE'LL
TRY. THREE TWENTY FOUR THREE
TWO FOUR. OPPOSED TO THE BILL
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
LIME THREE TWENTY. THREE TWO
ZERO. MY NAME IS DANNY BURKE
I'M A RESIDENT OF JORDAN DOW BY
GOOD LUCK BUT CALIFORNIANS AND
I'M IN SUPPORT. LIME. THREE
NINETEEN THREE ONE NINE. MY
NAME IS AVAILABLE AND SALAS ON
BEHALF OF THE ALSO TREATING
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT A PRESENT
STATE AND THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP OF SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THANK YOU VALLEY WILL
DEVELOPMENT CENTER AND THE
FRESNO HOUSING AUTHORITY.
PEOPLE SUPPORT. LINE. TWO FIFTY
EIGHT TO FIVE EIGHT. RUBBER MAX
SHORTY COMMUNITY RE POWER
MOMENT WHAT'S CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. LINE. FOUR ELEVEN FOUR
ONE ONE. OR ELEVEN IS YOUR
PHONE ON MUTE. HOME OF THE LINE.
FOUR OH ONE FOUR ZERO ONE.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES HI
THIS IS AMBER HERNANDEZ WITH
THE SOUTHEAST COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION AND WE
ARE BOTH A PART. WE HAVE LINE.
FOUR ZERO FOUR FOUR OH FOUR. HI
CAN YOU HEAR YES YES CHIRLA YOU.
HI THIS IS A PHILADELPHIA URBAN
PEACE INSTITUTE AND SUPPORT.
AND WITH THAT I DON'T KNOW FOR
THE LINES IN Q. THANK YOU. AND
WE'RE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. C. NO
QUESTION FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
MIX- DESCRIPTION YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I SIMPLY
WANT TO SAY. THAT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO REPRESENT- A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS NOT BEEN
ABLE TO BE CONNECTED TO THE
INTERNET- HAVING ACCESS IS VERY
DIFFICULT- WHEN YOU HEAR
RESIDENTS WHO HAVE NO ABILITY
IN TERMS OF THEIR CHILDREN
BEING ABLE TO EVEN CONNECT
EDUCATIONAL. PROGRAMS TO THE
TEACHERS BECAUSE- HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS THERE WAS BUILT A
YEARS AND YEARS AGO ARE MADE OF
CONCRETE THEREFORE THE
INTERNET- SIGNALS CANNOT
PENETRATE CONCRETE WALLS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN WHO HAVE
LEARNING LOSS IN NOT ONLY MY
COMMUNITY BUT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I KNOW
THERE WAS SOME CONCERNS INTO
THE REAL COMMUNITIES WHAT ROLE
COMMUNITIES WILL NOT BE LEFT
OUT I'VE HEARD THE VOICE OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO REPRESENT SHASTA
AND LAKE TAHOE WHERE YOU HAVE
TO DRIVE TEN MILES IN ORDER TO
GET A SIGNAL AND SO THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO MAKING
SURE THAT EVERYONE IS IN FACT
CONNECTED WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT AGAIN- TAKING GENERAL
FUND MONEY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MONEY. AND THE TELEKINETIC A
SEARCH OF SURCHARGE BUT TO BE
ABLE TO FUND THIS PROGRAM WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO CALIFORNIA'S- THE
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING AND THOSE DO NOT THOSE
WHO ARE CONNECTED AND THOSE WHO
ARE NOT CONNECTED WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR CHILDREN
HAVE NO LEARNING LOSS EXPECTED
DURING THIS TIME OF THIS
PANDEMIC. AND MR A CHAIR AS
WELL AS- MET MEMBERS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A VERY
PRUDENT- WAY TO GO- THIS IS A
SENSIBLE WAY TO GO IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE IS IN
FACT CONNECTED AND I APPLAUD MY
COLLEAGUES BOTH IN THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY TUBES TO RALLY
AROUND THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
BUT ALSO WON'T TAKE MY
COMMUNITY. FALSO COMING ONLINE
AND ALSO STATING- THEIR AYE
BOTH BROTHERS NICKERSON'S
JORDAN IMPAIR COURTS CONTACT
VILLAGE- THOSE ARE COMMUNITIES
I'M MOST PROUD OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES. THAT I'M WORKING
AND STANDING ON THE FLOOR
FIGHTING WILL BE OF I RISK. NOW
WHEN I'VE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
YOU- COMMITTEE WE NEED TO
PERSIST. MISTER GARCIA- THIS
CROSSOVER SECOND THANK YOU-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. IN THIS BILL DOES ENJOY A
DO PASSED THE COMMITTEE OF
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU.
MOTIONS TO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION SANTIAGO I'M
SANTIAGO AYE PATTERSON.
BOERNER HORVATH CERVANTES
DAVIES DAVIS NOW EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA I HOLDEN LOW
COKE SILVA QUICKSILVER I
RODRIGUEZ. VALLADARES CALAVERAS
KNOW BENNETT TAKING. THREE TWO
MEASURES ON CALL THREE TWO
MEASURE IS ON CALL AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO- MR COOK IF YOU'RE
AVAILABLE. AND I WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND- REPEAT ONE MORE TIME.
ACTUALLY PROCEED NOW REPEAT
WILL GET A FULL COMMENTS MADE
AGAINST CORK ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE FIRST
OR WHEN IT WAS KNOWLEDGE THE
POINTS MADE OF THE ANALYSIS- WE
DO THINK IT IS RIGHT THAT THE
JURISDICTION COME UP WITH A
SAFETY PLAN THAT THE- INSTALLER
OF THE EQUIPMENT SHOULD FOLLOW.
I KNOW IT DOESN'T READ THAT WAY
RIGHT NOW BUT WE WILL FIX THAT
AND THERE ARE SOME ADDITIONAL
THINGS WHICH THE LAWYERS ARE
TALKING ABOUT NOW IT'S NOT
QUITE AS STRAIGHTFORWARD AS
WE'D LIKE IT TO BE BUT WE WILL.
IN FACT- FIX THAT- WORDING AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN. OCTOBER
NINETEEN AS HIGHLIGHTED THE
NEED FOR BROADBAND ACCESS AND
THE GAPS THAT STILL EXIST
ACROSS THE STATE. IN SERVICE
AND ACCESS. OR FUNDING IS
CRITICAL TO FILL THAT GAP. SO
IS THE NEED TO ENSURE RAPID
DEPLOYMENT OF BROADBAND
PERMITS. AB FIVE THREE SEVEN
MODIFIES THE STATE BROAD
BANDING PERMITTING PROCESS. TO
ENSURE LINES WITH UPDATED
FEDERAL RULES. AND MAKE SURE
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MAKE
DECISIONS WITHIN FEDERALLY
MANDATED TIMELINES. THAT ARE
TYPICALLY TWO TO THREE MONTHS
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF
PROJECT. IN TWENTY FIFTEEN I
AUTHORED LEGISLATION THAT
ESTABLISHED A SHOT CLOCK
REMEDY. FOR PERMITS THAT WERE
NEVER ACTED UPON BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITHIN FEDERAL
TIMELINES. WELL THIS
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN HELPFUL IN
PRIORITIZING THE PROCESS SEEM
TO BROADBAND PERMITS. WE'VE
SEEN INSTANCES WHERE
DISAGREEMENTS OCCUR. AROUND
WHEN THE SHOT CLOCK STARTS-
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE STOCK
SHOT CLOCK ENDS. AB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN WILL PROVIDE CLARITY
AROUND THE STARTING POINT FOR
THE SHOT CLOCK. AS WELL AS
CLARITY FOR THE EXISTING DEEMED
APPROVED PROCESS AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THE SHOT CLOCK.
THESE CLEAR. WILL MAKE SURE THE
INTENT OF MY ORIGINAL BILL IS
REALIZED AND REDUCED AMBIGUITY
IN THE LAW. THIS BILL WILL MAKE
A REAL DIFFERENCE TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS SUGGEST
DESPERATELY NEED IMPROVED
INTERNET ACCESS FOR SCHOOL
TSHOLOTSHO TELEHEALTH REMOTE
WORK COMMERCEIT WILL MAKE SURE
THAT HIGH SPEED INTERNET
PROJECTS ARE DELIVERED. IN
MONTHS INSTEAD OF YEARS. HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE THREE SEVEN. IS DAN
SCHWEITZER ON BEHALF OF CROWN
CASTLE AND PEDRO NAVA FROM THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION AND
ALSO A FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
THANK YOU. THE BIGGEST CLERK
WILL GIVE TWO MINUTES EACH AS
OPPOSED A EAGLE TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS DANIEL PIPES ARE ON
THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR CROWN CASTLE THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRKY AND
CHAIR SANTIAGO FOR YOUR YEARS
OF COMMITMENT. ALL AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
BECAUSE THAT WILL ALLOW HIGH
SPEED INTERNET PROJECTS TO BE
COMPLETED IN MONTHS INSTEAD OF
YEARS. CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS
PERMITS SHOT CLOCKS IN PLACE
FOR BROADBAND PROJECTS THANKS
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORKS EIGHTY
FIFTY SEVEN FROM TWENTY
FIFTEEN. THIS BILL UPDATES
CALIFORNIA LAW TO REFLECT THE
NEW FEDERAL TIMELINE THAT WERE
RECENTLY ADOPTED SO THE SHOT
CLOCKS ARE CONSISTENT IT ALSO
PROVIDES CLARITY AROUND WHEN
THE SHOT CLOCK STARTS IN THE
PROCESS AFTER THE CONCLUSION OF
THE SHOT CLOCK. EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE IT PRESERVES LOCAL
CONTROL BY ALLOWING CITY USE
WHATEVER PRODUCT THAT THEY WANT
TO EVALUATE BROADBAND PROGRESS
M. AND IT WILL ALLOW THEM TO
APPROVE OR DENY THE PROFIT FROM
IT. ALL THE BILL DOES IS MAKE
SURE THE CITIES MAKE A DECISION
WITHIN FEDERALLY MANDATED
TIMELINES WHICH ARE TYPICALLY
TWO TO THREE MONTHS DEPENDING
ON THE TYPE OF PROJECT. THIS
BILL WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE IN NEED OF
IMPROVED INTERNET ACCESS FOR
SCHOOL TELEHEALTH REMOTE WORK
AND COMMERCE IT'LL MAKE SURE
THAT HIGH SPEED INTERNET
PROJECTS ARE DELIVERED IN
MONTHS INSTEAD OF YEARS. EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN WILL CONTINUE
IN THE SUCCESS OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK'S EIGHTY
THIRTY SEVEN WHILE UPDATING THE
LAW TO PROVIDE MORE CLARITY AND
CONSISTENCY IT WILL LEAD TO
COMMUNITIES GETTING QUICKER
ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED INTERNET
PROJECTS WHILE MAINTAINING
LOCAL. CONTROL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. MR NOT. FIFTY
MINUTES. THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M PEDRO
NAVA AND I'M CURRENTLY THE
CHAIR OF LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION BUT I'M HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THREE
SEVEN THE COMMISSION IS AN
INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN
OVERSIGHT AGENCY CHARGED WITH
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
THE COMMISSION ISSUED A REPORT
URGING CALIFORNIA TO IMPROVE
AND EXPAND ACCESS TO DIGITAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICES TECHNOLOGY
HAS REVOLUTIONIZED THE WAY IN
WHICH CALIFORNIA'S X. ACCESS
AND RECEIVE INFORMATION AND THE
STATE MUST INNOVATE TO PROVIDE
THE PUBLIC WITH CONVENIENT
DIGITAL SERVICES THEY HAVE COME
TO EXPECT IN OUR REPORT
ENTITLED A CUSTOMER CENTRIC
UPGRADE FOR CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT WE FOUND THAT HIGH
SPEED BROADBAND HAS BECOME AN
INTERNAL CHANNEL FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO ACCESS CRITICAL
SERVICES BOTH FROM THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. IT EXPANDS ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE AND EDUCATION AND
ENABLE SMALL BUSINESSES TO
EXPAND THEIR MARKET REACH. IT
GENERATES GREATER CIVIC
PARTICIPATION BY MAKING IT
EASIER FOR CALIFORNIANS TO FIND
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
GOVERNMENT AND IT CAN
STREAMLINED STATE PROCESS THESE
BY OFFERING THEM ONLINE. OR
THROUGH APPS ACCESSIBLE
ANYWHERE YET IN ITS TWENTY
TWENTY ISSUE BRIEF ON
CALIFORNIA'S DIGITAL DIVIDE THE
COMMISSION FOUND THAT AS MANY
AS TWO POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LACK ACCESS TO
BROADBAND. HIGH SPEED BROADBAND
ACCESS IS NEEDED NOW MORE THAN
EVER. IT FAR TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE LEFT WITHOUT-INTERNET ACCESS OR LACK
SUFFICIENT BANDWIDTH TO MEET
THEIR HOUSEHOLD NEEDS. AS THE
STATE WRAPS UP ITS DIGITAL
SERVICES PORTFOLIO IT WILL BE
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACESS TO
AFFORDABLE RELIABLE BROADBAND
COVERAGE. IN THIS REPORT THE
COMMISSION URGED STATE LEADERS
TO MAXIMIZE OPTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO CONVENIENTLY
ACCESS DIGITAL GOVERNMENT
SERVICES. AB FIVE THREE SEVEN
WITHVANCE THE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATION BY INCREASING
ACCESS TO RELIABLE HIGH SPEED
BROADBAND. THE BILL WOULD MAKE
SURE THAT ALL LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS UTILIZE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S BROADBAND
PERMIT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE- A TWO TIME
WITH CATHERINE DODD DR
CATHERINE DODD- AND WE HAVE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED- CAT
THREE RYAN AND WILL BEGIN NOW
MISTER- MODERATE. FINDER OPEN
WITNESSES THE MAN TESTIFIED.
THIS IS CATHERINE DODD GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND SANTIAGO
AND MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
THANK YOU. I'M A REGISTERED
NURSE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF NURSES
FOR HEALTHY ENVIRONMENTS WE
WORK AT THE LOCAL STATE LEVEL
TO KEEP CALIFORNIANS HEALTHY
AND SAFE FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
TOXINS AND HAZARDS. THIS IS A
VERY UNUSUAL LEGISLATIVE
SESSION WITH MANY BILLS MOVING
QUICKLY OFTEN PREVENTING
THOROUGH UNDERSTANDING OF THE
LONG TERM CONSEQUENCES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHILE FOCUSING ON
VACCINES OPENING BUSINESSES AND
SCHOOLS AND FOR SOME PREPARING
FOR THE WORST FIRE SEASON IN
HISTORY. MOST OF AN UNABLE TO
FOCUS ON THIS LEGISLATION WHICH
REMOVES THEIR AUTHORITY OVER
HOW TO KEEP THEIR RESIDENTS
SAFE FROM THIS PROPOSED
UNREGULATED EXPANSION OF
WIRELESS TOWERS AND FACILITIES
ARE IN TENNIS ALL COVERED IN
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. WE AGREED
THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS ACCESS TO
HIGH SPEED SPEED INTERNET FOR
EDUCATION BUSINESS
COMMUNICATION AND TELEHEALTH
HOWEVER AB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
DOES NOT PROVIDE SAFE
AFFORDABLE SECURE HIGH SPEED
INTERNET AND IT WILL NOT IMPACT
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. CURRENTLY
IN THE PERMITTING PROCESS FOR
LOCAL AND PERSONAL WHILE
WIRELESS TELECOM FACILITIES
DOES VARY FROM CITY TO CITY
THESE PERMITTING PROCESS SEEMS
WHICH THE FCC WERE. REFLECTS
THEY WERE FOR THE LOCAL
RESIDENTS SAFETY EXPERTS
ELECTED OFFICIALS PLANNERS TO
DANGER FROM MENTIONED JANET
DENSITY WITH ITS ACCOMPANYING
EXPOSURE TO NON IONIZING
RADIATION AND FIRE DANGER.
TELECOM FIRES ARE ELECTRICAL
FIRES AND POWER MUST BE CUT OFF
BEFORE EXTINGUISHING CAN BEGIN
HOW THE STARS ARE FATHERS
DETERMINED BY FIVE LOCAL FIRE
DEPARTMENTS THE PLACEMENT OF
THESE WIRELESS FACILITIES MUST
BE DETERMINED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL NOT BY TELECOM CARRIERS.
WE MUST PREVENT FIRES IN THE
FIRST PLACE PROTECT RESIDENTS
OF FIRES DO OCCUR BY CAREFUL
ZONING WOULD. SET BACK TO ALLOW
PREVENTION AND- S. AND PREVENT
SPREAD. THE FCC AND- CHOSE TO
INCLUDE. THE QUOTE A PRO AND
THEIR ROLES AB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN WILL GO WELL BEYOND THE
FTC AB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
ALLOWED DEEMED APPROVAL FOR
CONSTRUCTION. TO BEGIN EVEN IF
THE PERMITTING PROCESS IS NOT
COMPLETE ELIMINATION OF LOCAL
CONTROL DOES NOT PROVIDE SAFETY
FOR ANALYSIS. AB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN POSES A MAJOR THREAT TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY AND WE
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU TALK ABOUT. AND
WE HAVE- MISS PHRYNE. HELLO CAN
YOU SHARE MEMBERS ACTUALLY
BRING THAT UP OKAY. CALIFORNIAN
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
CHINESE. OR ANYTHING CALIFORNIA
AND THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE POSITION OF
THE CALL MY CEMENTED Q. FIVE TO
SEVEN. UNNATURAL WHERE THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT POIGNANT
TYPICALLY LOWER INCOME WHILE
AREAS THAT LACKED THE NECESSARY
ACCESS TO EVERY DAY FOR THE
FOLKS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO BE AN ADEQUATE OR NOT. AT
THAT POINT WHERE THEY LEFT.
MIKE NUMBER CORPS LOCAL. HAVE
MADE THE OF BROADBAND THE
PRIORITY TO YEAR. OKAY THANK
YOU CAN AGREE THE STATE OF
MONTANA TELCO LINES SHOT
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA LOT IN. AND
EVEN ALLOWED TEAMED UP TO FROM
THE CALORIE. TIMELINE HELLO
THERE IS FAR MORE. THAN THAT
OUTLINED IN THE FILM BUT THAT'S
EXACTLY EIGHTY FIVE THREE SEVEN
INCLUDING LINE. TO THE DANGER
PRODUCE. THAT THAT THE WAY PUT
HOW. FACILITY IF I FIFTEEN
ISSUE AGAINST MAYBE. THANKS FOR
WHAT PRACTICE NEEDS TO MERE
FACT CARTER SECOND LET. IS TO
STOP. ADDITIONAL EIGHTY FIVE
THREE SEVEN THANK THE SHOT
CLOCK. SUB AGAIN THE AFTER IF
THEY THE KERN PROCEDURE PAPA
PAPA. THIS POINT WHERE IS ALSO
IN THE THING BECAUSE IF YOU CAN
IF YOU GET INTO. WE OF FAMILY
MEMBER COURT EFFORT TO INCREASE
ACCESS BUY THEIR- HOWEVER WE
NEED TO. THE NARROWED IS BETTER
THAN TO THE CRIME BECAUSE T.
PLEASE GROW FOR THE CASES BUT A
LOT GOVERNMENTS TO MEET THE
PRESS. RIGHT. TWO DIVISIONAL
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- ENEMY WILL HEAD
REPEAT IN- WILL HAVE A
TELEPHONE OPEN- AND ALL PUBLIC
COMMENTS FOR A TOTAL OF THIRTY
MINUTES- FOR ALL ME TOOS WHICH
INCLUDES YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY IN ORDER SURE
THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE TIME TO
HEAR ALL THE BILLS TODAY. AS
NOTED BEFORE THE BE A COMMITTEE
HEARING- AFTER THIS IN THE
CHAMBER. AGAINST ST GERMAIN
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
AND WILL BEGIN BY ASKING IF
THERE'S ANY- WITNESSES. IN THE
CHAMBERS HEN WILL BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON PAUL MCGOVERN FROM
WIRE AMERICA I HAVE A POINT OF
ORDER ON TO ON THREE BILLS HERE
TODAY I NEED AN ANSWER FROM THE
CHAIR ON EIGHTY NINE NINE FIVE.
ONE ONE SEVEN SIX ONE FOUR TWO
FIVE I'M ASKING WHY WE ARE
ACTUALLY CUTTING OUT THE PUBLIC
FROM BEING A POSITION ONLY WHEN
THERE AREN'T THE WITNESS IS OUT
OF ORDER IN IS RIGHT YOU ARE
NOW DISRUPTING THE HEARING. WE
WILL PROCEED ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE
CHAMBER. NOW WE'RE GOING IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
OPPOSITION- IN THE ROAD STATION.
ANY ADDITIONAL OR SUPPORT-
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE IN WILL BEGIN NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
STATE YOUR POSITION ON EIGHTY
FIVE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE THAT'S A ONE AND ZERO.
HELLO FIRST TO LINE. TO FIFTY
SEVEN. NEXT ON THE LINE. THREE
FIVE EIGHT THREE FIFTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WORKING IN COLD
REPRESENTING THE WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSOCIATION. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
LINE FOR THIRTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL GUNNING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR EXPELLED.
LINE. FOR THIRTY FOUR. FORTY
FOUR ARE YOU ON MUTE. OVER A
LIME THREE EIGHTY FIVE THREE
EIGHT FIVE YES CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES I THINK YES. I AM VERY.
STRONGLY OPPOSED. TO EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU.
WELL OVER LINE THREE OH EIGHT
THREE ZERO EIGHT. YES MY NAME
IS JOHN RAYMOND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE UP WITH FIG PRE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL FOR THE FOR THE SAKE OF
OUR YOUTH. HEALTH AND- RECENT
AND POSITION ONLY THANK YOU
NEXT. LIME. THREE EIGHTY ONE
THREE EIGHT ONE. THIS IS COMP
ANDERSON WITH THE WIRED IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE AT FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE FOR THIRTY SEVEN.
MATTHEW HARPER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. LINE. THREE SEVENTY TWO
THREE SEVEN TWO. M. THREE SEVEN
TWO ARE YOU I MEAN. OVERLAND.
FOR THIRTY THREE FOUR THREE
THREE. SO MANY EMILY ABRAHAM
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU. NEXUS LINE.
THREE NINE FIVE THREE NINETY
FIVE. HI MY NAME ISJAY GROOME
HE- FOUNDER AND CEO OF THE
BALANCED RUNNER IN ONLINE
EDUCATION BUSINESS AND I AM
STRONGLY AGAINST THIS BILL AND
ASK- FOR NUMBER. THANK YOU.
LIME. THREE TWENTY FOUR THREE
TWO FOUR. MORE MOVED. TO TWO
SEVENTY SIX TWO SEVEN SIX.
HELLO YES MY NAME IS ANNETTE
SIMMONS FORMER COUNCILMEMBER
AMERICAN THAT CITY AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED SP. FIVE THREE
SEVEN. EXIT LINE. FOR THIRTY
SIX FOUR THREE SIX. WHAT A LINE.
TO EIGHTY FOUR TWO EIGHT FOUR.
YES MY NAME IS THE DOCTOR ARE
YOU CALLING FROM CONTRACOSTA.
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. IN LINE. FOR TWENTY
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT. HELLO
YEAH LINE UNTIL YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
JERRY NELSON DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR STATE
TECHNOLOGY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB. FIVE THREE SEVEN. TEXAS
LINE. FOR THIRTY FIVE FOUR
THREE FIVE. HI AND MY NAME IS
TO LOOK OVER AND ON WITH
WIRELESS RADIATION EDUCATION
AND BEGAN. AND I DESPERATELY
OPPOSE AB FIVE THREE SEVEN.
LINE. FOR THIRTY EIGHT FOUR
THREE EIGHT. YES HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES THANK YOU OKAY HI YES MY
NAME IS KATHLEEN GUILL DRESS
AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
ENVIRONMENT DEVELOPMENT WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN. NINE THREE OH TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THREE ZERO TWO.
HELLO MY NAME IS SYDNEY ****
I'M CALLING WITH SAFE PICK FOR
SANTA ROSA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FIVE THREE SEVEN
THANK YOU. LIME. THREE TWENTY
NINE THREE TWO NINE. YES MY
NAME IS B. BECAUSE BARRY WOULD
STOP FIVE G. CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIVE THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU LINE.
FOR TWENTY NINE FOUR TWO NINE.
HELLO THIS IS PAMELA WHITMAN
FROM GRASS VALLEY NIGHT
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU. LINE.
FOR SEVENTEEN FOR ONE SEVEN.
FOR SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE'RE GOING TO TWO TWENTY EIGHT
TWO TWO EIGHT. KEVIN MODIFY AND
OUTREACH DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BRAIN TUMOR
ASSOCIATION AND WIRELESS IS
DEFINITELY NOT GREEN TECHNOLOGY
AT LEAST TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF
ENERGY FEDERALLY THEY'RE USING
FIBER TO NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY NAME
ORGANIZATIONS IS AN ONLY THANK
YOU. TWO FORTY ONE LINE TO
FORTY ONE. KATHLEEN A BIRD FOR
PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES ARE BEING
DESTROYED BY EXTENDING
IMPOSITION CONDENSATION. AB
FIVE THREE SEVEN OPPOSE OPPOSE
OPPOSE. THREE TWO THREE NINE
THREE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS A WAS APART
FROM THE CITY OF PHILADELPHIA-
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FIVE THREE SEVEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BLIND. FOR
THIRTY FOUR THREE ZERO. HI THIS
IS ANIS CERITA WITH THE BAY
AREA CUNSEL IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LIME THREE FOUR SIX
THREE FORTY SIX. CHERYL
MATTHEWS ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
SAFE TECHNOLOGY OUR MEMBERS
FROM ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. PLEASE VOTE
NOW. NINE TWO SIX TWO TWO SIXTY
TWO. NINE TWO SIX TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WILL MOVE THE LINE.
FOR TWENTY SIX FORTY SIX. YES
HELLO MY NAME IS JEFF LERNER IN
FAIRFAX MY STAND WITH THE TOWN
OF FAIRFAX AND I OPPOSE AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN PLEASE VOTE NOW
THANK YOU. LINE. FOR THIRTY ONE
FOUR THREE ONE. HI THIS IS TOM
REPORTER FROM STATE K. SANTA
ROSA AND I OPPOSE STRONGLY.
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. LINE.
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE THREE
FIVE ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS
VICKY FEVERS EMF SAFETY NETWORK
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
REMOVES IMPORTANT PUBLIC INPUT.
LINE. FOR TWENTY SEVEN FOUR TWO
SEVEN. AND I THINK STRONGLY
OPPOSED. LINE. FOR EIGHTEEN FOR
ONE EIGHT. HELLO THIS IS
STEPHANIE THOMAS A CO FOUNDER
OF WIRELESS RADIATION EDUCATION
AND OFFENSE WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO AB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN.
LINE. FOR SIXTEEN FOR ONE SIX.
WITH WHICH WHEN YOU'RE ON YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOUR FOR SIXTEEN.
I AM. YES I AM TALKING TO ME
YES YOU TALKING TO ME ENTENDIDO
STRIPS OF THE GODS OKAY- MY
NAME IS BONNIE MCMURRAY I'M
FROM CENTRAL CALIFORNIA I AM
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED TO IT AB.
FIVE THREE SEVEN PLEASE VOTE NO
ON IT. BLIND. TWO FIFTY SEVEN
TWO FIVE SEVEN. LINE TWO FIFTY
SEVEN ARE YOU ON MUTE. LINE FOR
TWENTY FIVE OR. TWO FIVE.
PARENTS DONALD MYERS AND
SENATORS CALIFORNIA PEDESTAL
MEYER ARE RAN I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EIGHTY FIVE THREE SEVEN. LIME.
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN THREE SEVEN
SEVEN- NANCY MCCORD BLOOD SKI
WITH NAPA ASSOCIATION FOR SAFE
TECHNOLOGY STRONGLY OPPOSING AB
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. LINE. FOR
TWENTY FOUR FOUR TWO FOUR. THIS
IS JENNIFER LOW CORDIAL WITH
CITY TECHNOLOGY FOR SANTA ROSA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. FIVE
THREE SEVEN. NO I HAVE THREE
TWENTY FIVE THREE TWO FIVE IS
OPEN. AMONG THE. FOUR FOUR
THREE NINE FOUR FORTY THREE.
I'M HAN FROM TO HECTOR DRING
THE SERVICE IN VANDERVELL
CALIFORNIA I STAND WITH MY VERY
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU. BY AND.
FOR FORTY FIVE FOUR FOUR FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN
HIRE PEOPLE COME OUT AND WE'RE
SHOULD GROUP ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
LINE. FOR FORTY SEVEN FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON BOB
WILLIAMS FROM WATER AMERICA
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL
BECAUSE THE DEFINITION OF A
SMALL NAME WE'RE GONNA ZETIAN A
POSITION ONLY. LINE. FOUR FOUR
FOUR FOUR FORTY FOUR. EACH YEAR
FROM WEST TENNESSEE IN FACT
COMMITTEE I REPRESENT A MAN MAY
DIE SEEING OUT COMMUNITIES WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN. ONE THREE FORTY
THREE FOUR ZERO. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES MA'AM. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. YOU CAN YES
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT YES. OKAY
MY NAME IS JANET SAID CHERYL
FROM MARIN COUNTY AFFILIATED
WITH CALIFORNIA CANCER
SURVIVORS AND MOTHERS IN FAVOR
OF LOCAL CONTROL TO PREVENT
FORCED RADIATION I OPPOSE
GREATLY A PA. THANK YOU. LINE.
FOR FORTY SIX FOUR FOUR SIX. HI
MY NAME IS THEIR ANIMALS UNION
CITY CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
WITH THAT THERE ARE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU. MANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THE FLINTSTONES. WE'RE
THE FIRST TO THE SECOND BIGGEST.
AND WHOSE FIRST- THE FIRST WAS
FROM THANK YOU SECOND. SEVERAL
OF MR SEAH. A FEMALE A
QUESTIONS ANY CLOSING COMMENTS-
THANK YOU AYE AS WE ARRIVE VOTE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK. WITH
THE- OPPOSED UNTIL UNLESS
AMENDED FOLKS AND TRYING TO
FIND LANGUAGE WE CAN ALL AGREE
ON. THANK YOU- THIS BILL DOES
ENJOY DO PASSED THE COMMISSION
APPROPRIATIONS- MASSACRED
PLEASE CALL ROLE. MOTIONS TO
HAVE TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO ON PATTERSON.
BOERNER HORVATH CERVANTES
DAVIES DAVID SIGN EDUARDO
GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA I HOLDEN.
LOW QUOTE SILVA FLIP SILVA I
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ SIGNED
VALLADARES. GALLAGHER SIGN
BENNETT. TAKING. SIX ZERO
MEASURES ON CALL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE SCORE I WILL BE
MOVING ON TO AB. ELEVEN SEVENTY
SIX. CRISTINA BEGIN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRPERSON MR RODRIGUEZ
JUST IN THE SECOND. THE
PROMOTION SECOND NIGHT I WILL-
PRESENTE BE ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
CALIFORNIA CONNECT FUNDED ON
MARKET IS TO LEGISLATION WILL
AFFECT MY MISTER GARCIA. RIGHT
THAT'S GONNA BE THE SECOND
ARAMBULA CHECK- WE WILL- FOCUS
ON THE CONTENT HERE ELEVEN
SEVENTY SIX PROVIDES A UNIQUE
SOLUTION TO PROVIDING DISCOUNTS
ARE ACTUALLY TO THE HOUSEHOLD
AND ALLOW THE CUSTOMER AND THE
ABILITY TO CHOOSE WHAT PLAN AND
WILL PROVIDE A WORKS BEST FOR
THEM AND THEIR HOUSEHOLD- THIS
IS PART OF A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT BILLS. THAT ARE
ATTEMPTING TO BRING-
CONNECTIVITY CLOSER TO THOSE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO- HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY- MISSED OUT- DUE
TO THE LACK OF INVESTMENT INTO
INFRASTRUCTURE ACCESS TO
PORTABILITY PROGRAMS AND
CLEARLY DURING HIS PANDEMIC
CAT- THIS IS BEEN HIGHLIGHTED
SIGNIFICANTLY SO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU-
WE HAVE. TO SUPPORT WITNESSES
FOR AB ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX AND
THAT. MS OR DURAL AND MISTY AND
WE HAD WE HAD ONE LISTED
OPPOSITION WHICH IS MISSED-
MISTER WHETHER BAPE LATINIST
AND THERE'S A SECOND. AND THAT
WOULD BE- PAUL MCGAVIN AT BOTH
ALSO TWO MINUTES- IF WE CAN
BEGIN WITH THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON WENT AWAY WITH WHAT.
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HEAR
ME. TO SUPPORT EIGHTY ELEVEN
SEVENTY SIX WHICH WOULD
INCREASE BROADBAND ACCESS BY
PROVIDING SUBSIDIES TO LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS INTO NEEDS
FOR HIGH SPEED INTERNET TO THE
CALIFORNIA CONNECT FIND. MANY
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS REMAIN
DISPROPORTIONATELY DISCONNECTED
FROM BROADBAND ASKING FOR MORE
RECENT SURVEY THAT FOUND OVER A
QUARTER OF A LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA. AND CONNECTED UNDER
CONNECTED MEANING THEY DEPEND
ON THEIR SMARTPHONE FOR
INTERNET EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
OFTEN HAD TO MAKE TRADE OFFS.
THIS PAST YEAR MANY WORKERS
LOST THEIR JOBS FORCING THEM TO
FORGO SERVICES TO SAVE MONEY
INCLUDING DISCONNECTING THEIR
INTERNET SERVICE. OKAY NEED FOR
BARE BONES SERVICE PLANS
WITHOUT SUFFICIENT STREAMING
CAPACITY CALIFORNIANS IN RURAL
AREAS PARTICULARLY HIT HARD AND
INTERNET ACCESS CAN BE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE EXPENSIVE
OUTDATED TECHNOLOGY. AT A TIME
WHEN THE PAIN THEN I CAN MOVE
SCHOOLS JOBS AND EVEN HEALTH
CARE ONLINE THIS BILL IS
ESPECIALLY TIMELY THIS BILL IS
A CRITICAL STEP TOWARD
EXPANDING BROADBAND ACCESS AND
PROVIDING I DON'T HAVE TO WAIT
TO. CONNECT CALIFORNIANS TO
NECESSARY HEALTHCARE AS WELL AS
OTHER VITAL SERVICES WE HAVE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS TO
STREAMLINE THE LITTLE INCOME
QUALIFICATION LANGUAGE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATION BETWEEN AND ABOUT.
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IN THIS WAY.
MODERATE IF YOU COULD HELP US
FIND THIS WAY. ABOUT THAT WAS
MISPLAYED THIS IS SERENA OR DO
ROLE THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR. I
APOLOGIZE. YOUR HONOR I WANT TO
GET YOU MAYBE GET. THANK YOU
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER SAID
A TRIPLE CAL GOING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THREE NO
ZERO AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CULINARY INSTITUTE I AM
GRATEFUL TO COMPARE SUPPORT FOR
A BI ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX. DEGREE
LENDING INSTITUTE IS A POLICY
RESEARCH ORGANIZING AND
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE WORKING
FOR RACIAL AND ECONOMIC EQUITY
NEARLY 22% OF CALIFORNIANS
AREN'T CONNECTED OR UNCONNECTED
TO THE INTERNET USUALLY BECAUSE
THEN ACCESSIBLE COST TOO MUCH
FOR TOO MANY FAMILIES. THIS
AFFORDABILITY BARRIER AFFECT
LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
COMMUTERS. THE MOST. WHEN
REMINDING IN YOUNG STUDENTS OF
COLOR OUR REPORT ON THE HARM TO
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. WE HEARD
STORIES ABOUT STUDENTS
EXPERIENCES OF THE CLASS THING
HARD BY THEIR INABILITY TO
ACCESS AFFORDABLE AND ADEQUATE
BROADBAND. A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD
FAMILYWENT INTO THAT YOU TO
BROADBAND COSTS AND HAVE THEIR
INTERNET CONNECTED TWICE FOR
NON PAYMENT. HER FAMILY
BORROWED MONEY FROM FRIENDS AND
FAMILY TO PAY THE BILL BECAUSE
OF HOW SENSUAL BROADBAND
SERVICE WAS FOR EDUCATION AND
HER SIBLINGS EDUCATION. NO
FAMILY SHOULD HAVE TO GO INTO
THAT TO TRY TO ACCESS SERVICES
LIKE BROADBAND CONNECTION BUT
THE CAPABILITY. TO SUCCEED AT
SCHOOL AND WORK. YOUR AB
ELEVENTH SIX BUT HOW CANNOT
FUNCTION CLOSE. CENTRAL TO. BY
PROVIDING FOR TO BONTA
INTERACTION. WILL ENABLE ENTIRE
FACT THAT THEIR NET AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY IMPROVE
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES AND
PROVIDE A WAY TO CLOSE THE
RACIAL WEALTH GAP. FOR TRADERS
WITH HOME INTERNET 415217%
HIGHER ON STANDARDIZED MATH
SCIENCE READING TASK LOCAL LACK
ACCESS. THAT GAP ONLY GROWS
WITH STUDENTS GET OLDER IN
ADDITION HAVING SAID TIMES
SCHOOL FROM HOME FOR THE
COMPANY IN PENTOMIC HAS ONLY
AMPLIFIED THE HARM OF THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE TO STUDENT
SUCCESS. ENSURING THAT THE
STUDENTS CAN GET EDUCATION WITH
THE TOOLS THEY NEED A
SUBSTANTIAL PARK BUILDING AN
EQUITABLE FUTURE. AB SEVEN X.
OF CLOSER DIVIDE TO ESTABLISH
THE KERR. TAX FORTY REASONS THE
GREEN LINE INSTITUTE AFTER YOU
JOIN US IN SUPPORTING AB.
ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX. OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY WE'RE CALLING- MISTER
WEATHERBEE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHECKING HERE ME YES THANK YOU.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR IN
MEMBERS DUSTIN WHETHER BE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSES AB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
BECAUSE THE BILL WOULD IMPOSE
AN ADDITIONAL TAX UP TO TWENTY
THREE CENTS A MONTH TO FIND A
NEW CALIFORNIA CONNECT PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE PC. TO
PROVIDE EVERY ELIGIBLE LOW
INCOME AND STUDENT HOUSEHOLDS
IN THE STATE A SUBSIDY TO PAY
FOR ANY CHARGE RELATED TO
AFFORDABLE BROADBAND SERVICE
AND DEVICES MAKE NO MISTAKE AB
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX IS A
SIGNIFICANT TAX INCREASE.
CALIFORNIANS ALREADY PAY
SIGNIFICANT TAXES ON THE PHONE
SERVICE AND EIGHTY ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX MAKES PHONE SERVICE
EVEN MORE EXPENSIVE BY ADDING A
SEVEN TAX TO TAXPAYERS PHONE
BILL BUT YOU BY CHOOSING TO USE
THE PHONE BILLS ACTIVELY TAX
COLLECTION SERVICE FOR NEW
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES CALIFORNIA IS CHOOSING
TO MAKE THE COST OF THE PHONE
LESS AFFORDABLE. ON AVERAGE A
TYPICAL WIRELESS CUSTOMER IN
THE STATE PAY MORE THAN 23% OF
THE TOTAL PHONE BILL AND FEES
TAXES AND SURCHARGES THE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND TWENTY TWENTY.
WE ALSO QUESTION WHETHER
ADDITIONAL REVENUE IS NECESSARY
AT THIS TIME THE OTHER
CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE FUNDS
FOR THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
ACT WHICH INCLUDES FUND THEIR
EARMARKED FOR BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND
SUBSIDY PROGRAMS WE ARE
CONCERNED I TAX INCREASE RESULT
IN TAXPAYERS PAY FOR SIMILAR
PROGRAMS BY. THE EMERGENCY
BROADBAND BENEFIT PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE FCC
STARTING THIS MONTH PROVIDED
SUBSIDY OF FIFTY DOLLARS PER
MONTH TO ELIGIBLE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS TO PAY FOR BROADBAND
SERVICE. IN ADDITION WITH THE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING PROVIDED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE
STATE IS PROJECTED TO HAVE A
RECORD TWENTY TWO BILLION
DOLLAR RESERVES WHICH IS WHY
THE GOVERNOR AND ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS HAVE STATED THAT
ADDITIONAL TAXES ARE
UNNECESSARY IN THE CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT. GIVING THESE
REASONS CALTEX LET'S
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB. ELEVEN
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE
MORE WITNESS- TWO MINUTES
OPPOSITION PLEASE. YES THE
SERGEANTS WILL DIRECT YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU MY NAME IS PAUL
MCGANN FROM WHY AMERICA AND I
WANT TO HAVE TWO MINUTES A
TRUCE HERE TO TELL YOU WHY WE
NEED TO PLAY THIS JUST CAME A
LITTLE MORE DIFFERENTLY. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND AND
YOU'RE SAYING THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IS A BIG
DEAL I'M GONNA POINTS TO A MUCH
BIGGER NUMBER THAT SIXTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS. AND THAT IS
THE MONEY THAT WAS ACTUALLY
ILLEGALLY TRANSFERRED FROM YOUR
STATE TELECOMMUNICATIONS PUBLIC
UTILITIES TO THEIR WIRELESS
SUBSIDIARIES IN ORDER TO BUILD
THE FOUR G. NETWORK IF YOU WANT
SOME REAL MONEY TO REALLY CLOSE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE THAT'S WHERE
IT IS. IT'S ON THE BOTTOM LINES
OF THESE COMPANIES THAT HAVE
ENGINEERED THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
VERY CRAFTILY OVER THE YEARS TO
COME MAKE SURE WE WERE IN THIS
DESPERATE POSITION SO THEY CAN
ACTUALLY PUT MORE WIRELESS IN
PLACE YOU UNDERSTAND THE TITLE
TO IS WHAT YOU NEED HERE IT'S
YOU PUBLIC UTILITY THAT MUST
PROVIDE SERVICES THAT JUST AND
REASONABLE RATES. THEY ARE THE
SOLUTION HERE THEY NEED TO PUT
FIBER OPTIC DIRECTLY TO EVERY
HOME AND BUSINESS AND CHARGE A
JUST AND REASONABLE RATES AND
WHY IS THAT BECAUSE WE PAID
FIVE TO SEVEN DOLLARS PER MONTH
PER PHONE BILLS SINCE THE
NINETEEN NINETIES NOR TO GET IT
DONE. AND THAT WAS
MISAPPROPRIATED AGAINST THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ACT SECTION
TWO FIVE FOUR K. THIS IS
NOTHING LIKE THAT SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN IT SHOULD NEVER BE TAKEN
AWAY FROM UTILITY AND PUT TO A
PRIVATE COMPANY YET IT DID
FORTUNATELY THE A REGULATORS
SUIT AGAINST THIS IN FEDERAL
COURT AND YOU CAN NOW CORRECT
ALL OF THIS MISS MARTIAN
SHENANIGANS. GOING ON FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND YOU CAN GET
SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS BACK TO
REALLY CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
SO I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO THAT A
LITTLE BIT BROADER IN A LITTLE
BIT FURTHER THAN THE TALKING
POINTS GIVEN TO YOU BY THE
LAWYERS AND LOBBYISTS BY CROWN
CASTLE WHO IS NOT A C. LET GO
AND I LOOKED AND HAS NO ROLE IN
THIS MATTER. AT THE END OF THE
DAY YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT YOUR
STATE PUBLIC TELECOMMUNICATIONS
UTILITIES LOOK NO FURTHER. THAN
AT&T CALIFORNIA AND- PRESERVED
MONEY BY TO THE- THEY CAN FIX
THIS PROBLEM. AND WE LOOK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR INPUT- WE ARE
THE FIRST TO THE SECOND- I
BELIEVE. I'M SORRY YEAH AND- IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS- FARM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR OF ONE OF
KNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF YOUR
COMMITTEE TEAM. AND YOURSELF
WE'VE WORKED ON THIS POLICY
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE- THEY
SAID IF YOU'RE WANTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN BRING
AFFORDABLE. PROGRAMS CLOSER TO
CALIFORNIANS WHO MOST NEED- TO
ACCESS. BROADBAND AND WE KNOW
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS DESERVE
THE RIGHT TO HAVE. A GOOD
QUALITY AND AFFORDABLE HIGH
SPEED INTERNET TO ACHIEVE THEIR
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES-
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MOTIONS TO PASS TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I
PATTERSON. BOERNER HORVATH THE
HOBBIT NOT VOTED CERVANTES
SEVEN TO SIGN DAVIES DAVIS NOW
AND WATER GARCIA HI EDUARDO
GARCIA I HOLDEN. HOLDEN I LOW.
HELLO I COOK SILVA. COOK SILVA
NOT BURDEN. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
SIGNED VALLADARES. GALLAGHER IS
NOW SENATE SENATE HIDING. SEVEN
TWO MEASURES OUT THANK YOU KNOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE NEED A FIRST AND
SECOND. THE FIRST AND SECOND
I'VE BEEN AND A THIRD AND I'VE
BEEN ADVISED FOR THIS CONSENT
CALENDAR TO TAKE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN A LITTLE WHILE ONE
PERSON FOR TWO MINUTES IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS ITEM-
MISTER PAUL MCGOVERN I BELIEVE
YOU ARE- PROVIDING PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. CONSENT AB NINE FIVE
FIVE AND AB ONE FOUR EIGHT
THREE DEPOSIT COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION RECOMMEND CONSENT
SANTIAGO. IS THERE NO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. TO BE CLEAR. FROM
THE PHONES MISTER. FOR A
PARTICULAR GOVERNMENT. YEAH
JUST TO THE SERGEANT- HE HAS
BEEN ALLOWED TO TESTIFY FOR TWO
MINUTES MISTER PALMER GAVAN ON
THIS ITEM.
AND WE'RE GONNA GET
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
MISTER MCGEE I'M SOME OF START
TIME NOW THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- PALMA GAVIN WIRE
AMERICA AND ICE DIED ON BEHALF
OF OUR ORGANIZATION OF
THOUSANDS PLUS ALMOST FOUR
MILLION ELECTROMAGNETIC
SENSITIVE. CALIFORNIANS ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. AND YOU HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE A
BIG STAKE IN ALL OF THESE
WIRELESS BILLS. BECAUSE IF YOU
PUT TOO MUCH OF SIGNAL NEXT TO
OUR HOMES. YOU WILL FORCE US TO
MOVE BECAUSE IT TORTURES US.
AND THIS IS REALITY. WE ARE OUT
FINALLY AT THE BREAKING POINT
HERE. THERE'S TOO MUCH
ELECTROMATIC POWER THROUGH THE
AIR. FOR HUMAN BEINGS TO
WITHSTAND. AND THE GOOD THING
THAT WE CAN DO IS TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT IS ENOUGH TO GET THE
JOB DONE. SO WHAT ALL OF THESE
BILLS IF YOU COULD HAVE PLEASE
REAL TECHNOLOGY NEUTRALITY AND
SAY. ANYTIME YOU PUT FIBER IN
THE PUBLIC RIGHTS OF WAY GIVE
PEOPLE ACCESS TO IT SO GO
WIRELESS AT ALL. THAT GIVES
CONSUMER CHOICE IN IT IS THE
BEST INTERNET SERVICE. I KNOW I
HAVE IT ONE GIGABIT DOWN WE'LL
GIVE IT UP TELEPHONE LINE FIFTY
BUCKS A MONTH. THAT'S WITHOUT
TITLE TO YOU DO IT THROUGH
EIGHTEEN T. CALIFORNIA YOU GET
THOSE BILLS NOW TO THIRTY BUCKS
A MONTH AND HAVE THOSE KINDS OF
SPEEDS. YOU JUST HAVE TO FINISH
THE JOB. IT ACTUALLY WAS ALL
DESIGNED TO DO THIS AND IT WAS
GONNA BE FINISHED BY TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN BUT THE WHOLE
AGENDA CHANGED. IF YOU GO BACK
TO THE ORIGINAL PLANS THE
ORIGINAL BROADBAND PLANS.
THAT'S WHAT NEEDED TO BE DONE.
WIRELESS IS JUST A CHEAP
ALTERNATIVE DEFINITION EVERY
WIRELESS NETWORK IS 99% WIRED
ANYWAY. THEY'RE JUST STOPPING
SHORT THE LAST 2% OR 1% TO
SPRAY THAT YOU TO MAKE MORE
MONEY TO STAY ON REGULATED. IF
YOU TAKE IT ALL AWAY BY WIRE
YOUR REGULATED TITLE TO PRICING
EVERYBODY WHO CAN'T AFFORD IT.
THE WORST COMPANY KNOWS THIS
THAT'S WHY THE PLAYING THE
CHESS GAME THE WAY THEY ARE.
I'M ASKING EVERYBODY JUST LOOK
AT THE REAL SOLUTIONS HERE THE
DOLLARS ARE HERE THE WILLIS
HERE YOU JUST HAVE O WALK AWAY
FROM THE WIRES AGENDA. IN STATE
AND THEY'LL CHARGE BLOCK FAR
AWAY I'M NOT CLOSE TO PEOPLE
THANK YOU TWO MINUTES FOR UP TO
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND INPUT WE APPRECIATE IT-
WE HAVE THE FIRST SECOND ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- MANCHESTER
PLEASE HOLD ALL. CONSENT
CALENDAR NINE FIVE FIVE AND AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE DUPATTA
COMMITTEE ON PROCREATION RECKON
CONSENT SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
PATTERSON FOR THE WHOLE THAT.
BUT A HOLE THAT I CERVANTES.
CERVANTES SIDE DAVIES DAVEY
SIDE EDUARDO GARCIA. EDUARDO
GARCIA I HOLDEN. HOLDEN ARI LO
LO ON A QUICK SILVA. QUICK
SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
FIVE VALIDATORS. VELADERO SIDE
BENNETT FENIT I TAKING. ELEVEN
TWO ZERO MEASURES ON CONSENT.
THANK YOU. OUR MEMBERS NOT GO
THROUGH- THE ROLE AGAIN TO THE-
ABSENT MEMBERS GOING OUT ON-
NAMES OKAY PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS. AND LET'S BEGIN WITH
THE ON CALL SOMEBODY ELSE. I
DON'T NUMBER ONE. AB NINE EIGHT
EIGHT OUR K. M. CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO. PATTERSON NOT BURDEN.
CERVANTES. CERVANTES SIDE.
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I LOVE. LOW I.
TAKING. NINE TWO ZERO MEASURES
OUT. ON CALL ITEM NUMBER AB
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE GIPSON. CURRENT
VOTE THREE TWO PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO. BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I. CERVANTES
CERVANTES SIGH. HOLDEN. HOLDEN
I LOW. LOW I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE BENNETT BENNETT I
PAYING. NINE THREE MEASURES OUT.
I DON'T NUMBER THREE AB FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN COAL CURRENT VOTE
IS SIX ZERO. PATTERSON FIVE
PATTERSON I BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I CERVANTES
SEVEN TO SIGN HOLDEN. HOLDEN I
LOW LOW HI BENNETT BENNETT I.
TEN TWELVE TO ZERO MEASURES OUT.
FILE ITEMS. I REMEMBER FOR. AB
NINE FIVE FIVE COOL INSYNC
CALENDAR PATTERSON PATTERSON I
TAKING. CONSENT CALENDAR.
TWELVE TO ZERO. I DN'T NUMBER
FIVE AB ONE ONE SEVEN SIX
EDUARDO GARCIA. FIVE ADD ON'S
PATTERSON. PATTERSON NO. TAKING.
SEVEN THREE. WHEN WILL BEGIN
AGAIN.
OKAY WE'RE ON THE LAST
BILL. I WILL WAIT FOR ADAMS
OKAY. I WOULD AGREE WITH. HELLO
GET AWAY FROM THE CITY YEAH
OTHER. WORDS. I DON'T AB ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB NINE EIGHT EIGHT.
TANG TANG I FINAL VOTE. TEN
ZERO. I DO NUMBER TWO AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE GIPSON
TANG TANG I. FINAL VOTE. TEN
THREE. MY ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN CORK TANG
TANG I FINAL VOTE. THIRTEEN
ZERO. I AM NUMBER FOUR AB NINE
FIVE FIVE AND AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE. CONSENT CALENDAR
TANG TANG I FINAL VOTE.
THIRTEEN ZERO. I NUMBER FIVE AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX EDUARDO
GARCIA TANG TANG I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT THREE. IF YOU CAN.
COMMITTEES ARE DONE.